bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur Public
Sénat hier la mission d'information
commune du Sénat sur l'affaire du
médiateor a entamé ses auditions les
sénateurs ont entendu le professeur
Jean-François Girard ancien directeur de
la santé et le professeur Hubert
allemand actu numéro 2 de la CNAM et qui
est pressenti pour devenir le nouveau
patron de lafsaps c'est ce médecin qui
déjà en 98 avait alerté l'ancien
directeur de lafsap sur les dangers liés
à la prescription du Médiator je vous
propose donc de suivre ces deux audition
très bonne matinée à tous mes chers
collègues donc nous avons l'honneur et
le plaisir d'auditionner donc monsieur
le professeur Jean-François Girard qui
est président de Sorbonne Paris Cité
mais qui et c'est important pour nous
hein non pas que ce soit important ce
soit pas important pour nous vous soyez
président de son Paris Cité mais vous
avez été directeur général de la Santé
euh pendant une période euh assez longue
he d'ailleurs je sais pas si le record a
été battu mais en tout cas vous avez été
directeur général de la Santé de 86 à 97
et c'est précisément au cours de cette
période qu'un certain nombre de de
décisions ont été prises concernant le
bain flux et sur lesquelles
effectivement nous aimerions vous
entendre alors j'ai pas besoin comme me
fait obligation euh la loi de vous
demander si vous avez des liens
d'intérêt euh je pense que la réponse
est négative ni à cette époque ni depuis
ni à cette époque ni depuis donc euh je
pense que nous pouvons passer sans
transition euh sauf si vous voulez dans
un premier temps euh faire une
déclaration
liminaire auquel cas si si vous ne
souhaitez pas Madame la rapporteur va
immédiatement commencer à vous poser les
questions qu'elle souhaite vous poser
pas de problème vous voulez faire une
déclaration il semble pas il est
probable que ce que je pourrais dire en
liminaire viendra très bien dans les
réponses que je tenterai d'apporter à
vos questions d'accord
doncureur rapporteur vous avez la parole
première question quand et comment
avez-vous été informé pour la première
fois des effets nocifs du Médiator et
quelle mesure avez-vous engagé alors que
vous étiez directeur général de la Santé
donc de 86 à
1997 et comment expliquez-vous 2è
question que le Médiator a fait l'objet
le 22 avril
1987 d'une validation
restrictive rester lettre morte pendant
une décennie comme le dit le rapport de
Ligas est-ce que vous le confirmez
lorsqu'enfin cette modification de l'AMM
intervient en avril
1997 elle sera de façon incompréhensible
annulée le 5 juin
1997 donc un mois après comment
expliquez-vous une telle décision
euh il aurait-il eu le rapport de ligaz
dit je cite entre guillemets une
instruction d'un des responsables de la
direction
d'évaluation j'aurais d'autres questions
ensuite sur le bfleesque on va peut-être
voilà commencer par ces deux questions
si vous le si vous pe Souha d'accord
donc vous avez la parole monsieur euh
le le Président Monsieur le Président
pardon madame le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs
je vais dire quelque chose de stupéfiant
qui vous paraîtra
stupéfiant je n'ai aucun souvenir de
cette période et de ces événements je
dis pas cette période de ces
événements c'est lorsque exerçant
d'autres métiers et l'actuel en
particulier que que j'ai pris
connaissance y compris des actes que
j'avais
signés alors effectivement cette
situation m'a interpellé cela peut faire
faire un commentaire banal sur euh les
fléchissement de la mémoire à partir
d'un certain âge on en parle beaucoup en
ce
moment deè deè ça arrive à tout le monde
deuxièmement ça fait effectivement euh
une quinzaine
d'années deuxièmement c'est un
commentaire plus hypothétique et presque
de la part d'un médecin ou quelqu'un qui
s'est intéressé un peu à la
physiologie peut-être que mes molécules
d'n
largement sollicité depuis par des
métiers tout aussi épuisants que celui
de la Direction générale de la santé ont
dû faire de la place à autre chose j'ai
exercé la présidence de l'Institut de
Recherche pour le Développement pendant
8 ans et le métier de président de d'un
pôle de recherche et d'enseignement
supérieur à Paris depuis 9 10 mois n'est
pas une finicure
voilà le trè trè remarque que je ferai
sur cette faillite de la mémoire est
peut-être le plus
intéressant ou en tous les cas celui qui
éclaire le mieux le fonctionnement de
l'administration en général en tous les
cas de celle que je con que j'ai connu
la direction général de la
santé je me suis repris en disant que
lorsque j'ai dit je n'ai pas de souvenir
de cette époque je n'ai pas de souvenir
de ce dossier par contre j'ai des
souvenir très précis avec une actuité
intéressante sur des débat sur le sida
sur des campagnes sur ce qui a comp qui
a assister en la conduite du pilotage du
dossier de la lutte contre le sida à
cette époque j'étais le délégué
interministériel de la lutte contre le
sida j'ai aussi des souvenirs très
précis de la crise de la vachef et j'en
déduis donc que le métier directeur
général de la santé est un métier où on
ne voit pas
tout où on s'investit beaucoup dans des
dossier
lourd aux yeux du directeur général de
la santé aux yeux des ministres qui l'
servi aux yeux de la société et que
d'autres dossiers à cette époque-là ont
pu
paraître je ne dis pas moins lourd mais
en tous les cas ne pas impliquer de la
part du directeur lui-même et de sa
mémoire le même type
d'investissement cela étant et c'est un
constat positif que je fais à l'endroit
de la Direction générale de la santé je
vais revenir sur ses
responsabilités euh je crois que cela
veut dire aussi que j'avais une
confiance en mes collaborateurs et que
si j'ai signé un arrêté un arrêté c'est
même pas une décision c'est un arrêté
publié au Journal officiel c'est qu'il
était assorti d'un fond de dossier que
j'ai lu avant de signer même si j'eni
pas de souvenir et qui m'a convaincu je
parle de l'arrêté de 1995 ou oui les
deux arrêté et je pense que c'est
effectivement ce type de mécanisme qui
caractériser la Direction générale de la
santé des dossiers lourds qui impliquai
en première ligne le directeur général
après de son ministre et des dossiers
qui étaient les autres et qui
nécessitaent quand même un traitement et
que cela prouve que les 300
fonctionnaires de cette maison à cette
époque étaient capable d'assurer
l'essentiel comme ce qui pouvait
paraître à l'époque plus secondaire
alors cette expression de plus
secondaire aujourd'hui peut paraître
étonnante mais je voudrais madame le
rapporteur si vous permettez euh
préciser que la diretion générale de la
santé on peut reprendre son périmètre
ses fonctions ses attributions mais a
coexisté au cours de toute la période
que vous avez évoqué avec une direction
de la pharmacie du médicament qui a été
transformé au moment de la loi du début
93 je crois même c'est le 4 janvier 1993
c'est de mémoire je dis ça
en l'Agence du
Médicament devenu maintenant l'Agence
des produits de santé grâce au Sénat
aussi 98d grâce aussi au
Sénat grâce au Sénat et au gouvernement
de Lionel Jospin
absolument que de bonne faà que de bonne
faitm pardon ce ce cette mise au point
enfin conduit à un débat probablement
mais je ne ferai que si vous le
permettez à évoquer un peu l'expérience
que je tire à cette époque et depuis car
j'ai gardé un certain œil y compris au
travers de rapport que j'ai
pu réaliser à la demande du gouvernement
2006 en particulierveil sanitaire on
vous interrogera sur ce rapport donc je
je soulligne qu'à cette époque là en
tous les cas la Direction générale de la
santé coexistait avec une
désadministration une forme
d'administration d'abord la dphm
Direction de l'administration centrale
puis une agence et que clairement les
attributions de la Direction générale de
la santé ne ne concerernent pas le
médicament sauf chose que je ne
comprends pas les préparations
magistrales oui oui et c'est parce que
peut-être parce que les préparations
magistrales les quelques pharmaciens
s'en étonneront s'il en est dans la
salle que les préparations magistrales
n'est pas le même statut que le
médicament moi je ne saurait pas vous
expliquer même rétrospectivement
pourquoi le médicament était dans les
les attributions de l'Agence du
Médicament ça on peut peut-être
comprendre et pourquoi les préparations
magistrales étaient confié à la
Direction générale de la santé on se
prend à regretter vous savez ave leul
hein que vous n'ayez pas eu aussi les
médicaments bah oui mais oui enfin ça il
y avait une direction du médicament et
une agence on peut c'est un autre débat
de savoir quelle est la taille les
périmètres des administrations en tous
les cas je je souligne ce pointlà et et
ce n'est pas
pour j'ai pas l'habitude et j'ai trop
fréquenter de crisees sanitair pour
pouvoir prêter le flanc à la
défusse je suis un coutumier de
d'Arcueil c'est-à-dire du pôle
judiciaire et depuis Lacas la vache
folle au sang contaminé en passant par
les hépatites la Clinique du Sport et et
la miante je crois que on a un devoir de
d'analyse de vérité certes mais
d'analyse dans dans tous c fait ce qu'on
appelle les crises sanitaires donc ce ne
sera pas de la défausse mais je
reconnais que à cette cette époque-el la
coexistence d'attribution enfin la
coexistence d'administration différentes
rendait en tout les cas je le vivais
comme
tel le directeur général attentif au
respect des
frontières je je en disant cela je
reconnais que celle-ci était
éventuellement l'objet les frontières de
d'affrontement entre des des façons de
voir pour ne pas parler de personne et
que
euh je crois que ce débat là est très
important il est beaucoup plus général
que le seul point le débat sur le
médiateur mais encore une fois je crois
que c'est aussi un des éléments qui peut
expliquer que ce dossier n'est été dans
une expression dont je ne voudrais pas
qu'elle soit qualitative un dossier
secondaire à cette époque-là aux yeux de
la Direction générale de la santé par
rapport à la vachool au sida
sous-entendu c'était un dossier qui
relevait des agences de des PHM la
direction de Ph la pharmacie du
médicament puis de l'Agence du
Médicament madame la rapporteur
euh donc je voulais vous poser la
question puisque vous aviez
signé ce décret arrêé pour les
préparations c'est arrêté
pardon magistral pourquoi cette
interdiction n'a pas été n'a-t-elle pas
été étendue aux préparations
pharmaceutiques vous venez implicitement
nous en donner la réponse ce n'est pas
de votre
responsabilité pourquoi aucun lien n'a
été établi avec le retrait de
l'Isoméride en
1997 et comment expliquez-vous que selon
le rapport de liigas de 1987 à
2001 les responsables de l'évasion du
médicament de l'agence je cite on fait
passer la promesse de nouvelles études
de la de la firme dont ils connaissaient
pourtant les faiblesses avant
l'application de leur propre décision
constatant la très faible efficacité
thérapeutique du
Médiator je ne sais pas répondre à
question la première pourquoi n'a pas
avoir
étendu pris des mesures concernant
l'Isoméride c'est vrai que je n'ai pas
toutu y compris dans la période
actuelle encore une fois parce que je
suis encore en activité par ailleurs
mais clairement je j'ai signé un arrêté
qui relevait desattributions de la
Direction générale de la santé et je
n'ai pas eu la curiosité ni le temps
pardon de parler de temps d'aller me
mêler des attributions d'une autre
direction ou d'une agence c'est un débat
Jeuris pas don le sentiment que ça
puisse exonérer la l'ensemble du
dispositif de savoir mieux répondre à ce
genre de situation mais le fait est que
euh
je pense effectivement que la
multiplicité disons le nombre simplement
la multiplicité pourrait donner une un
sens le nombre des des acteurs le nombre
des agences qui interviennent dans les
politiques de santé et suscite des
questions sur le nombre leurs interfaces
leurs coordination et la puissance d'une
organisation de tutelle non pas de tut
on reviendra là-dessus si vous permettez
parce que on peut vous interroger sur
ces questions sur lesquelles vous avez
d'ailleurs fait un rapport euh sur le
médiateur j'ai sur médiateur alors moi
je voudrais bon effectivement je
comprends bien que vous avez signé ces
arrêtés et que si j'en juge par la
lettre qui a été adressé par l'un de vos
chargés de mission euh à l'Agence du
Médicament ça n'était pas vous qui
suivez je le comprends hein directement
ce dossier mais est-ce que vous pensez
que cette personne hein ce chargé de
mission qui a
correspondu avec l'fsaps sur ce sujet
serait susceptible peut-être de nous
donner un certain nombre de
d'informations que vous pour des raisons
que vous avez expliqué et qui sont tout
à fait recevables vous ne pouvez pas
nous donner il s'agit de Hélène
sain-marie c'est elle qui est la
signatrice de cette lettre au sujet de
ces fameux deux arrêtés parce que
semble-t-il elle comprend pas bien
pourquoi après avoir signé un arrêté en
mai on vous demande d' signer un second
en octobre hein et avec juste raison on
se dit on aurait peut-être pu réfléchir
un peu plus et faire signer la un seul
arrêté en mai ou peut-être en juillet
mais ou peut-être en octobre mais deux
ça euh dénote bien que dans ce domaine
l'fsaps a beaucoup hésité quoi et c'est
la question que je vous
pose alors
euh je je n'ai pas plus de souvenir que
sur ce sur cet aspect que vous venez
d'éclairer que ce que je vous ai dit dès
le début oui c'est une lettre dans les
annexes du rapport je je préciserai
simplement qu'en quittant la Direction
générale de la santé je n'ai emmené
aucun document tout a été versé aux
Archiv nationaloui donc tout le dossier
est là moi je n'ai et du coup je peux
pas rafraîchir ma mémoire même quand je
pourrais prévoir de PR de préparer une
une audition comme celle-ci
euh donc je je ne sais pas répondre sur
l'articulation entre les deux arrêtés
sur la personne et sur le rôle de Madame
Sainte-Marie qui était
sous-directrice du
médicament je crois que c'est comme ça
que s'appelit de la Pharm nous avions la
pharma oui oui chargé de mission auprès
du sous-directeur de la pharmacie oui
alors voyez c'est premièrement je je
relève le titre de la sous-direction que
j'avais oublié c'est pas la
sous-direction du médicament c'est la
sousdirection de la pharmacie et en
particulier la Direction générale de la
santé était chargé du suivi des
professions de santé en général incluant
les professions pharmaceutiques et c'est
la raison pour laquelle il y avait une
sous-direction à la Direction générale
de la santé et en particulier une
sous-direction qui s'appelait de la
pharmacie n pas de médicament première
remarque deuxièmement madame
Sainte-Marie à cette époque là était
effectivement chargée de mission auprès
de Madame Slominski la sous-directrice
sloninski et madame Sainte-Marie est
devenue sous-directeur à la suite de
madame sloninski je sais plus si c'est
avant que je quitte ou après mais de
fait en toutous les cas la qualité de
Madame Sainte-Marie sont sérieux son
censre deintérêt général et sa
connaissance du dossier des la pharmacie
et de l'interface avec le médicament
n'est pas discutable et je ne suis pas
étonné que son nom apparaisse dans un
certain nombre de documents qui ont été
échangés avec la direction de la
pharmacie puis avec l'agent de
médicament est-ce qu'elle est toujours
en
activité Vous put répondre je vous prie
de m'excuser je ne sais pas répondre
très bien Madame la
rapporteur avez-vous d'autres questions
oui j'ai bon vous avez répondu sur la
situation regard de vos conflits
d'intérêts il en avez pas mais euh
est-ce que vous estimez que l'influence
des laboratoires en général est-ce
qu'elle est forte auprès des
administrations publiques et est-ce
qu'elle peut expliquer euh je cite aussi
là ce que dit Ligas l'incompréhensible
tolérance de lafsavs à l'égard du
Médiator les seuls laboratoires
pharmaceutiques que j'ai jamais vu dans
ma vie déjà je devais être fléché parce
que je ne recevais pas les visiteurs
médicaux à l'hôpital quand j'avais une
activité hospitalière mais je ferme la
parenthèse c'était une vie
antérieure par la suite donc les seuls
contacts que j'ai eu avec l'industrie
pharmaceutique c'est avec les
producteurs de vaccins le directeur
général de la Santé en tous les cas
entre 1986 et
1997 n'a jamais reçu les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques si il y a deux
exceptions il y en a une les vaccins ça
on peut comprendre parce que les vaccins
sont certes produits par des
laboratoires mais ils sont l'objet de
politique publique de politique
vaccinale avec un calendrier vaccinale
des responsabilités engagées par l'État
je n'irai pas jusqu'à avoir cette phrase
devant une salle ouverte de dire que
c'est l'État qui est prescripteur encore
que lorsqu'il s'agit de de vaccination
obligatoire on n'est pas loin de cette
situationl
donc je crois que le problème du vaccin
des vaccins est à part et j'ai j'ai
effectivement eu l'occasion de recevoir
et de m'entretenir avec des laboratoires
qui fabriquaient des vaccins l'autre
contact que j'ai eu très précis mais
c'est pour illustrer l'exclusion de tous
les autres c'est lorsqu'en
1996 les trithérapies euh contre le sida
sont apparu sur euh le marché si je peux
dire comme possibilité et que nous avons
décidé avec Monsieur guemard
probablement si ma mémoire est
suffisante le ministre de l'époque en
tous les cas i de euh généraliser très
vite l'accès
àthérapie là aussi c'était une politique
publique une décision de nous
débrouiller pour que ces médicaments les
trois sur la forme de trithérapie soit
accessible en quelques mois et c'est un
fait que nous avons réussi cela en 4
mois et qu'eectivement il a fallu le
faire avec un contact direct avec les
fabricants c'est vrai que la décision
c'est un parisme avec les vaccins la
décision de rendre les trithérapies
accessibles à tout le monde c'était une
politique publique c'était une politique
d'État et à ce titre là effectivement
c'est non pas l'Agence du médicament
mais le la Direction générale de la
santé qui s ce sujet là merci Monsieur
merci j'ai une deuxième série de
questions puisque notre mission concerne
l'évaluation et le contrôle aussi du
médicament nous sommes tenaces en la
matière puisqueà la suite de l'affaire
du viox le Sénat avait déjà élaboré un
rapport en 2006 etvec un certain nombre
de conclusions d'ailleurs de Ligas
aujourd'hui qui reprennent celle de
notre rapport mais en ce qui concerne le
débat sur l'organisation
institutionnelle de la sécurité
sanitaire aussi bien sur sa simplif
sur sa composition sur le resserrement
des agences vous en tant qu'ancien
directeur général de la Santé
avez-vous des propositions à formuler
pour améliorer
l'efficacité du dispositif et nous avons
noté que dans un article d'un quotidien
du soir qui est daté du du 15 janvier
2011 reprenant un rapport que vous aviez
émis en
2006 vous observez qu'il serait
souhaitable de rapprocher les agences
pour éviter la balcanisation réduire les
coûts et développer une culture commune
est-ce que ce rôle n'incombe-t-il pas au
comité d'animation du système d'agence
mise en place en 2008 et regroupant
autour du directeur général de la santé
les 10 opérateurs sanitaires ainsi que
linerme
c'est c'est toute l'histoire des presque
presque 20 ans de renforcement de
l'administration de la santé que vous
évoquez
madame la première agence le premier
embryon d'agence c'est 1992 qu'on a
appelé à cette époque le réseau national
de santé
publique j'ai eu une responsabilité dans
sa création et je dois dire d'ailleurs
que je n'avais pas été ce n'est pas les
crises sanitaires qui se sont accumulé
qui m'avaient conduit à imaginer qu'il
était indispensable qu'on ait un
observatoire de l'état de santé c'est
simplement que j'étais très impressionné
j'avais été très impressionné par un
voyage qui était pas un voyage
touristique bien sûr aux États-Unis en
1987 un an après mon arrivée d'avoir vu
ce que c'était que le CDC Center for
Disease Control et et de m'être juré
qu'on aurait un CDC en France voilà 87
et il a fallu
5 ans pour obtenir la création du réseau
national de santé publique car on oublie
trop qu'à cette époque là la santé
publique é une discipline visiblement
sans passerance en France c'est pas en
France ça c'est la première
agence globalement je fais vite
l'ensemble de la création du système des
agences a des côtés franchement positifs
et des côtés qui forcent à se poser des
questions l'aspect franchement positif
c'est c'est que le ministère de la Santé
dispose d'un ensemble de lieux
d'expertise qu'il n'avait pas
auparavant il a ainsi obtenu à une
période où les effectifs de la fonction
publique étaient tout sauf en croissance
c'était déjà vrai à cette époque
là 1500 personnes je connais pas le
nombre exact j'ai oublié mais c'est cet
ordre là si on fait la somme de toutes
les agences qui ont été créées et même
probement et même plusôt 2000 oui
absolument puisqu'on n pas loin de 1000
avec l'agence avec laaps donc toutes ces
agences ont donné une puissance de feu
au ministère de la Santé qu' l'avait pas
précédemment incontestablement ça c'est
les aspect
positifs cette puissance de feu en terme
d'expertise doit
permettre aurait dû permettre en tous
les cas c'était l'objectif que les
administrations centrales se focalisent
sur le métier d'une administration
centrale c'est-à-dire de faire de la
stratégie et d'appliquer les politiques
que les pr ministre définissent que le
gouvernement
définit
l'évolution au cours des années je pas
j'ai cité 92 mais 98 vous avez évoqué 93
la création de l'Agence du Médicament 98
la loi sur l'agent de sécurité
sanitaire plus tard la création de l'fse
devenu af7 et et il faut aller jusqu'à
la dernière date qui est la la fusion
préconisée par le rapport en question
entre l'fs et l'fsa c'est un des aspects
s'il le fallait je serais capable parce
que je m'y suis pas mal impliqué après
avoir été le président du conseil
scientifique de la FSA sur ce l'intérêt
de la fusion mais c'est pas peut-être
l'essentiel de cette
audition les les les questions déjà les
questions que pose ce dispositif après
que j'ai souligné les aspects positifs
les questions qu'il pose sont les
suivantes
la la
segmentation presque d'un grand secteur
par agence c'està-dire l'approche
sectorielle peut être un handicap pour
l'approche globale des problèmes de
santé les liens entre le médic les
produits de
santé le ce que l'on fait à l'ABM comme
on dit l'agence de biologie médecine de
biomédecine bref tout ce dispositif et
contribue à des politiques de santé donc
la la segmentation et le fait que l'on
traite du médicament indépendamment des
autres aspects des politiques de
santé conduit à une forme d'autarciie
intellectuelle dont je me je me demande
si 15 ans après que ce DISP é en place
il ne faut pas le l'analyser l'évaluer
et vérifier si les inconvénients sont
pas plus grands que les avantages
d'autre part
euh
le au-delà des de la
segmentation vous l'avez presque évoqué
en évoquant ce comité mis en place en
2008 le débat est de savoir qui pilote
et voilà et justement si segmentation il
y a peut-être cela veut dire que le
pilotage doit être féroce et et que
fumis ce comité
je ne sais pas très sincèrement même si
j'ai un peu réfléchi à la
question le comité c'est pas 2000 vous
avez dit 2008 madame je crois que c'est
98 non je sais plus 2008 il a été mis en
place d'accord bon alors 2006 j'ai même
pas le comité donc on parle pas du
comité dans le dans le rapport et
effectivement je je ne sais pas répondre
sur la pertinence sur sur la performance
du du comité
mais sur le papier je trouve que c'est
bien c'est absolument indispensable et
pas seulement pour le de se réunir au
moment des crises c'est que c'est un
mécanisme de fond qui consiste à essayer
d'éviter justement les handicaps de la
segmentation enfin
euh la segmentation pour reprendre ce
mot me paraît avoir aussi une une
faiblesse dans les f dans les domaines
interministériel et
l'interministérialité qui est un sujet
euh omniprésent en matière de santé
heureusement la santé n'est pas que la
propriété du avenus de Ségure c'était
comme ça qu'on dit dans le temps
maintenant on dit duken je
crois mais euh la la le fait que par
exemple la sécurité alimentaire soit à
la fois sous l'autorité du ministère de
l'Agriculture du ministère de la Santé
et puis maintenant il y a aussi le
ministre de l'équipement et le ministre
du Travail
euh nécessite une analyse propre à la
gestion de ces grandes sécurités
sanitaires dans un cadre
interministériel et en particulier avec
quatre ministres et je je on pourrait
prolonger le débat mais je pense que là
aussi dans les évaluations à faire et
peut-être que ça serait ma conclusion de
devoir évaluer le dispositif maintenant
qu'il est alors j'ai dit 18 ans pour le
RNSP de V NVS mais c'est une dizaine
d'années pour la loi de 98 13 ans et je
crois qu'effectivement il est temps
enfin vous avez évoqué sans que le mot
soit prononcé madame le
rapporteur mais je l'ai compris un des
aspects qui est le suivi du médicament
bref la pharmacovigilance j' vous poser
la question tant au niveau des
signalements au niveau des
experts et au niveau décisionnel au
niveau des signalements que pensez-vous
par exemple de la prise en compte des
décisions de
ou de retrait d'Amn dans les autres pays
et des signalements directs des effets
nocifs par les patients et les
associations et comment mieux utiliser
aujourd'hui les données qui sont
recueillies par les centres régionaux de
pharmacigilance au niveau des experts
comment développer une expertise
indépendante des laboratoires et et
réduire les délais d'études
complémentaires des laboratoires et
lutter contre les conflits
d'intérêts et au niveau
décisionnel comment accélérer les
mesures de suspension et de
retrait tout en améliorant la
transparence et le pluralisme et comment
lorsqu'on a je sais pas 1 2 3 cas de
notification à quel moment doit prendre
doiton prendre la décision de retrait ou
non d'une mise sur le marché
encore une fois je je n'ai pas
directement eu de responsabilité sur
tous ces éléments de la chaîne je je je
parle le directeur général de la santé
peut s'intéresser un peu la
pharmacovigilance y compris depuis qu'il
a quitté ses fonctions mais je n'ai pas
vu fonctionner du
dedans sur la
pharmacovigilance j'ai j'ai une
position minoritaire mais n'a pas changé
depuis 93 et et redite dans le rapport
2006 oui la pharmacovigilance doit être
sortie de l'Agence du Médicament oui
vous voulez pour moi je n'ai aucunable
c'est une position minoritaire on peut
ouvrir d'un en trois phrases de débat
euh cette position que que je en faveur
de laquelle je plaide à savoir sortir la
facovigilance de l'Agence des
médicaments et simplement une
application certes élargie
du de savoir éviter les conflits
d'intérêts et de ne jamais laisser
quelqu'un consciemment intéressé ou non
intéressé inconsciemment peut-être aussi
être en position de juge et
parti je renvoie et vous n'en voudrez
pas contenu de mon appartenance au
Conseil d'État au rapport qu'a présenté
monsieur Sauvet la semaine dernière au
président de la République les grandes
règles qui certes découlent d'une de
situation un peu différentes peuvent
s'appliquer au débat don nous parlons
aujourd'hui la la notion de règle de de
de juger parti doit être absolument
appliquée il me semble
que ce soit la
même le même ensemble la même
administration euh qui
qui joue un rôle dans l'accès au
médicaments j'ai failli utiliser le
terme de Prome le médicament l'Agence du
médicament ne joue pas le même rôle que
la l'industrie donc l'industrie Prom le
médicament raison de oui oui il y a une
nuance forte mais l'agence du médicament
assure l'accès du médicament pour autant
qu'il remplisse les conditions de
légitime il joue un rôle dans l'accès au
médicaments est-ce que c'est la le même
ensemble qui peut être dans une position
de contrôle voire de défiance ou en tous
les cas de prendre en compte le moindre
signe
d'alerte c'est la raison pour laquelle
je pense que la la fonction d'alerte de
la
pharmacovigilance doit être sortie de
cette responsabilité c'est quoi la
fonction d'alerte après tout c'est
prendre acte d'un signe un symptôme
vous avez des boutons madame vient voir
son médecin parce qu'elle a des boutons
des grand une grandelorisant de boutons
à quoi c'est d hein ou si c'est un gosse
c'est plus facile est-ce que c'est une
maladie infectieuse ou est-ce que c'est
le médicament quand on voit le bouton on
va pas dire c'est de la
pharmacovigilance on est médecin on voit
un symptôme et ce n'est que si on fait
bien son travail qu'on dit mais vous
avez pas aussi pris un médicament c'est
bien connu bon ce que je veux dire c'est
que le dépistage du signe qui conduit à
la pharmacop ence est un acte
diagnostique médical qui nécessite
effectivement une déclaration quand on
pense qu'il y a lieu et les déclarations
ça se fait où ça se fait à l NVS les
déclarations sur l'état de santé de la
population que ce soit un cas 2 cas ou
plus ça se fait à l'InVS la la la la
logique de de l'InVS est précisément de
colliger toutes les informations sur
l'état de santé de la population et de
ces moindres variations fust-elle faible
f-elle subliminal fust-elle limité à
quelques éléments encore on sait comment
l'épidémie du sida a été détectée ENF
détecté a été évoquée au CDC lorsque
l'on s'est basé sur une consommation un
peu excessive de
médicaments donc je crois que cette
fonction qu'on appelle aussi La
pharmacoépidémiologie quelque chose qui
appartient plus à
la fonction de dépissage que la décision
qui en découle qui éventuellement un
retrait d'AMM revienne à l'agent du
médicament et que ce soit un acteur un
donneur d'alerte extérieur qui sera
plutôt senseur que protecteur et tant
mieux pour pour le malade ou pour la
population et pour la santé publique me
paraît légitimé cette cette boucle et
cette dissection de ce qui'est la
facovigilance monsieur
renationaliser la pharmacovigilance et
est-ce que vous avez par
exemple un modèle étranger sur lequel on
pourrait s'inspirer
alors l'expression
renation c'est une expression qui a qu'
emprunté Martin h c'est pour ça que je
la voulais savoir si vous étiez d'accord
ça prouve que je
elle m'étonne non pas parce qu'elle me
gêne mais parce que j'ai envie de vous
dire mais pourquoi elle avait été
dénationalisée mais faut pas prendre au
pied de la non voilà voilà ce que je
répond elle a été dénationalisé et si
c'est vrai je me dis mince alors une
fonction de santé publique euh qui qui
quiit à la sécurité enfin moi c'est
l'état hein je fait partie des fonctions
régaliennes dans ce pays en tous les cas
de l'État
euh alors je je peux revenir si parce
que ça renvoie à à ce que vous avez dit
la question que vous posé sur les
experts et
expertiseent donc sur ce point je je je
ne sais pas
euh nationalité ou des nationalité je je
pense qu'effectivement c'est un service
public qui peut faire appel comme
d'autres service public à des praticiens
en exercice libéral mais le service est
public devant répondre à des à des
règles à une organisation définie par le
service public là-dessus je je je je
pense qu'en fait que heureusement je
pense qu'elle n'a jamais été
dénationalisé mais le la distinction
entre euh l'analyse du de la conséquence
négative et aussi l'analyse de risque
parce que comme vous l'avez dit madame
le rapporteur à partir de quand vous
avez posé cette
question sollicitante à partir de quand
on
s'inquiète au bout de 2 cas 3 cas ou 10k
c'est une analyse de risque bon et ça
les analyses de risque ça c'est un
métier déjà ENF le rapport de 2006 je
crois l'avait fait il y a le
constat l'analyse du risque à partir du
constat et après la mesure et il y a
effectivement toute une série d'étapes
dans dans la gestion tout en crise comme
pas en crise des étapes qui conduisent à
la sécurité sanitaire et je pense
qu'effectivement l'intervention de
l'InVS ne devrait être que sur cette ce
ce segment qui est le recueil du
signe la l'intégration de tous ces
signes et l'analyse du risque pour que
après l'édion en découle enfin juste une
remarque mais elle m'est apparu très
fortement histoire de plaider
l'importance de la
pharmacoépidémiologie d'une façon
générale pour ceux qui n'ont pas compris
l'intérêt de la statistique et de
l'épidémiologie il faut regarder les
histoires de nos
crises le tournant a toujours été
lorsqu'il y a eu une étude française ou
étrangère qui a dit telle chose fait 200
500 ou 1000
morts de la miante c'est lorsque une
expertise collégiale de l'inerme en
1996 qui n'avait pas de précédent pour
chiffrer les risques a dit c'est une
expertise qui a été demandée par la DRT
la DGS a dit ça fait ça fera 2000 morts
ce jour-là les décisions ont été prises
dans les dans les semaines ou les mois
quand vous prenez le tabac c'est pareil
je vais pas je veux pas surtout en
audience publique souligner tel ou tel
produit mais
j'emprend de temps en temps il faut
savoir faire de la pédagogie et savoir
le décapfour pardon c'est une marque je
crois en plus je suis critiquable le
décapour oui ouais c'est un produit dont
on dit c'est dangereux faut pas le
laisser faut pas le mettre au au niveau
des petits enfants faut pas le laisser
voilà mais voilà voilà on continue tous
à utiliser du dcapfour il est en vente
je sais pas si c'est réellement
dangereux bon on est on est un risque
qualitatif de même qu'on était depuis
des décennies au risque qualitatif de la
miante mais il y avait pas eu de chiffre
le jour où pour le décapfour on nous
dira il y aura une étude faite avec des
épidémiologiste soit de Lyon soit
d'ailleurs ou de ville juif ça fait
temps les choses sont différentes voilà
je l'importance de l'épidémiologie de la
quantification entre un risque
qualitatif et un risque chiffrer et le
guide fondamental des décisions de
politique publique en matière de santé
publique vous avez raison si vous
permettez oui je voudrais revenir sur ce
que vous avez indiqué concernant vos
propositions concernant la
restructuration de notre système de
sécurité sanitaire puisqu'il s'agit de
ça en fait et vous préconisez dans votre
rapport donc que la
pharmacovigilance soit intégrée à
l'inves en gros c'est ça he et alors
est-ce que vous entendez par là qu'il
faut aussi auss euh intégrer à l'inves
tout ce qui concerne les vigilances en
général matériau vigilance toxico
viigilance enfit et cetera et cetera
parce que à mon sens voyez-vous je suis
d'accord avec vous pour reconnaître que
la la la commission de pharmacovigilance
la Commission nationale de
pharmacovigilance n'a pas suffisamment
d'autonomie par rapport à la Commission
d' mm elle devrait être en mesure de
prendre des décisions or jusqu'à présent
elle n met que des avis est-ce que vous
ne pensez pas que sans obligatoirement
la l'intégrer à l'inves en lui donnant
au sein de la structure quielle occupe
actuellement plus de pouvoir ça ne
répondrait pas finalement au souci qui
est le vôre je crois qui est de donner à
la
pharmacovigilance le poids qu'elle
devrait avoir dans notre sécurité
sanitaire et que malheureusement elle
n'a pas et l'exemple du médiateur est là
pour le pour le prouver hein et et parce
que un certain nombre vous avez bien dit
tout à l'heure que vous étiez
minoritaire c'est vrai hein mais oui un
certain nombre d'autres experts enfin
d'autres personnalités préconise plutôt
qu'on rapatrie euh ce qui concerne le
médicament et dans d'autres instances
dans une une une instance unique qui
traiterait de tout ce qui concerne le
médicament en particulier aujourd'hui la
Commission de la transparence se trouve
à la hasas et je pense que ça crée plus
de problèmes que que d'avant et on
aurait peut-être intérêt à la réintégrer
dans laapsap si tantz que l'apsaps doit
rester tel qu'elle est he sur ce planl
nous sommes en pleine réflexion et nous
ferons bien sûr des propositions mais ce
qui nous semble actuellement c'est que
le circuit du médicament est beaucoup
trop compliqué qu'il faudra forcément le
simplifier et la proposition que vous
faites va peut-être pas vers une
simplification mais en tout cas une plus
grande
autonomie susceptible de favoriser la
sécurité sanitaire donc oui à plus
d'indépendance
à la Commission nationale de
pharmacovigilance mais je me demande
est-ce qu'on doit la l'intégrer à
l'inves et si on le fait est-ce qu'on n
pas obligé de de rapatrier quoi toutes
les vigilances he qui sont vous le savez
assez nombreuses au sein de lasaps donc
c'est c'est la question que je pose et
quand une incidente à propos de HIRCH
quand il a voulu parler de
nationalisation il il devait parler du
financement
je crois que c'est ça actuellement les
agences sont financés par les labos donc
lui quand il dit nationalisation il veut
que ce soit financé par la l'état quoi
ce qui je crois va plutôt dans le bon
sens en tout cas selon moi sur sur le
financement je voudrais puiss compléter
et sous l'autorité de notre collègue
Vassel est-ce que vous pensez qu'il faut
réformer le dispositif de remboursement
en cas de service médical rendu
insuffisant monsieur monsieur Bassel a
cet effet en si par contract comment
expliquez-vous le maintien d'un taux
élevé de remboursement pour le
médiateor très pertinente
question je je alors je je vais essayer
de reprendre et de pas oublier deux
questions
euh il n'y a pas de raison de de ne pas
traiter toutes les vigilances de la même
façon
donc que que ce soit un sujet
difficile ma position de minoritaire
n'aténue pas mais on a besoin des
minoritaires ou oui en général très
deuxièmement
deuxièmement je n'ai jamais je n'ai
jamais travaillé à la saaps donc j'ai
c'est un atout et un handicap l'analyse
que je fais est une analyse vue du
dehors
troisièmement l'idée que vous avez
résumé qui circule de ramasser tout ce
qui concerne le médicament M me fich à
trouille je vous le dis ça s'appelle
l'endogamie oui bon oui oui et oui vousz
raison oui oui effectivement il je me
méfie risque je suis la tête d'un grand
bloc universitaire qui est
pluridisciplinaire et ça c'est très bien
bon je pense que lorsque vous laissez un
milieu pardon ce mot un peu un peu
technique un peu casendogamique euh on
prend c'est dangereux c'est vrai c'est
une règle vraie dans dans tous les
domaines
ensuite
euh comme ça c'est plus de l'endogamie
sur sur les enfin c'est aspect de
financement je crois
oui
euh c'est c'est premièrement l'expertise
parce que ça ça vient aussi
euh
le problème du financement est aussi lié
au statut des
experts j'ai moins réfléchi aux
expertises en général mais ça se pose
pas seulement mais elle se posait aussi
à la Direction générale de la santé
premièrement on peut être un spécialiste
sur un sujet àe on n'est pas un expert
àe on n'est pas c'est pas un statut
d'être expert on peut être enseignant
chercheur on peut être professeur de
pharmacologie ou et cetera maisre expert
c'est intervenir sur demande un jour
donné sur une question donnée avec
l'obligation de rendre la réponse dans
un temps
donné une fois que la réponse est rendue
on n'est plus expert on redevient
enseignant chercheur ou professeur de
pharmacologie de sur
TR la difficulté de de l'expertise en
général est qu'elle n'est pas valorisé
et même pas payé ça c'est vrai attendez
il faut aller jusqu'au bout pasement
médicament et pas seulement en santé
c'est du bénévola quand on fait venir
des chercheurs pour faire à la NR à
l'agence national de recherche bah voilà
alors eux ont un salaire quand on fait
venir quelqu'un qui travaille dans le
libéral je métais toujours insurgé
contre le fait qu'on ne P dédommageait
pas les généralistes qui passaient une
journée au ministère de la Santé pour
participer à une commission qui
débattait de la mission générale ce qui
était plutôt sain euh bah sauf que bon
c'était une journée d'acte perdue bon ça
n'a pas changé i je sais que ça pas
changé mais mais là il y a un vrai
problème et et quant à quant à ceux qui
sont qui ont un
salaire parce queils sont fonctionnaires
ou ont ils sont rémunérés par
salariat il faut forcément qu' une forme
de valorisation à faire l'expertise et
pour ceux qui est des des chercheurs
mais c'est si je parle des chercheurs
c'est pas parce que en ce moment je suis
dans ce monde là c'est parce que
effectivement c'est une source
d'expertise bon si vous voulez avoir des
des enseignants chercheurs pour expert
il faut faut qu'ils ai un intérêt au
lieu de travailler dans leur laboratoire
pour essayer de publier le plus possible
parce que c'est bien connu que c'est ce
qui fait avancer les parcours individuel
il faut que le temps qu'il passe
àexertise ou bien compte aussi dans
l'préciation de leur parcours
professionnel ou bien qu'il y a
desagents financiers que le chercheur
normal ne dédaigne pas vu le salaire
moyen du
chercheur très bien alors si vous le je
vais enfin passer la parole j'ai vous
voulez ajouter un mot ajouter parce que
nous sommes on est en 2011 oui je vous
en prie euh en 20 ans il y a un
interlocuteur qui a qui qui est associé
au pouvoir en général pris de décision
c'est le le le citoyen ou le malade les
associations ouais et il y a des
domaines où les associations sont très
présentes et il faut rendre hommage à la
façon dont s'est construite l'Agence
nationale de recherche pour le sida sur
le sida qui je crois parmi les premières
à associer les associations de malades a
des décisions qui compris des décisions
sur des protocoles thérapeutiques et
donc je pense qu'il faut là aussi dans
dans toute notre discussion tenir compte
du fait que bah cet interlocuteur doit
aussi faire partie des mécanismes de
décision et en tous les cas
d'organisation des sujets de santé
publique messieurs les commissaires
jeose pas vous appeler les missionnaires
puisque il s'agit d'une mission
messieurs les commissaires voulez-vous
avez-vous des questions à poser à
Monsieur
Girard monsieur monsieur
miratsou oui mesdames et messieurs
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs pardon vous avez dit en
préambule que votre mémoire est un peu
brouilléech permettez-moi de vous dire
qu'elle est sélective parce que dans un
autre registre vous avez une très très
bonne mémoire et en même temps la
capacité d'analyser de décortiquer le
système sanitaire français tel qu'il est
organisé avec vous l'avez dit du fait de
la multiplicité des agences manque de
lisibilité de la politique sanitaire
ù se surjoute de surcroix et et c'est
pas le moins important ce qui concerne
objeste mission une diluion patente de
la
responsabilité ma question elle est très
très très très simple elle est même un
peu brutale compte tenu ce que vous avez
dit en poussant la logique de votre
raisonnement à l'extrême considérez-vous
que l'épisode médiator est une fatalité
compte tenu de ce que vous avez décrit
au niveau du système sanitaire
français ma réponse va être biaisé parce
que la fatalité moi je connais pas hein
la maladie n'est pas une fatalité on
croyait ça il y a 30 ans maintenant on
s'aperçoit que ce qu'on mange dans notre
assiette ce qu'on respire
ou ou ce que l'on prend comme médicament
bon donc la fatalité
non pardon de cette vigueur et de cette
certitude
deuxièmement je pense mais c'est c'est
le travail d'une commission comme la
vôre monsieur le Président et de
quelques autres dispositifs qui
caractérisent les démocraties de
disséquer ce qui s'est
passé j'ose dire que ce serait trop
facile de considérer que il ne s'agit
que d'un sujet je parle du médiateur
illustré par l'agressivité commerciale
de son fabricant le dispositif public
doit être capable d'andiguer les
agressivités commerciales des fabricants
dans ce domaine là comme dans les autres
donc une fois queon l'a constaté si
vraiment on doit la
constater on a fait cl lati du travail
donc ça c'est la deuxème remarque la
troisème remarque c'est c'est
qu'effectivement et ça renvoie à ma
mémoire faillible ou
perceptible c'est que l'immensit ENF le
grand nombre de dossiers que l'on a
traité dans les sujets de santé
nécessite une sélection des choses
difficiles dangereuses et du reste et
que là comme ailleurs et comme mais
comme ailleurs comme en politique comme
on fait toujours des choix de priorités
et et des priorités qui après vous
pouvez le faire en fonction du risque
vous pouvez le faire en fonction
d'intérêt économique dans d'autres
domaines mais voilà et et que la gestion
d'une agence comme la saaps ou de la
Direction générale de la santé c'est
aussi de la part de son dirigeant un
problème de priorité et et et donc de
mémoire qui peut paraître faillible ou
sélective ah madame Goulet pardon pardon
madame rapporteur général d'abord non
non madame Goulet je une fraction
j'embrayais sur ce que disait notre
collègue Mirassou est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que en étudiant le le cas
du médiateor on va tomber sur d'autres
cas qui vont être qui vont émerger de de
scandales sanitaire et est-ce que vous
avez aussi l'impression
que la la perception très différente
entre aujourd'hui il y a 10 ans du
principe de précaution va aussi nous
amener vers vers d'Ares autrees
processus les les
deux
favorisant le courant minoritaire qui
devait être le vôtre sur une une
révision complète du du système du
médicament et de son contrôle
oui madame la président écoutez le
médiateur ça suffit hein je veux dire
qu'il y a pas besoin d'autres exemples
pour
faire considérer que le dispositif doit
être profondément remagé
bon je je je je ne sais pas parce
qu'encore une fois je je nai j'ai même
pas lu tout le rapport de Ligas j'ai lu
les 16 ou 18 pages attentivement de la
synthèse donc je je oui voilà oui il y a
sûrement d'autres situations qui
illustre les
mêmes mêmes difficultés de décision sur
mais on aura probement du mal aussi
c'est pas pour atténuer ma
réponse on aura le médiateur j'espère et
un des plus explicites bon le nombre de
morts mais il y aura bien sûr des
situations où on se dira est-ce qu'on
est dans l'acceptable
ou
ou le dangereux ou le non acceptable et
c'est l'éternelle question de
l'préciation du risque et voilà mais je
préfère qu'on soit dans cette situation
là que dans celle où effectivement on a
200 morts si ce chiffre est exa enfin et
d'être dans une situation
avée merci monsieur Vassel
oui euh just une question qui
n'appellera peut-être pas une réponse
immédiate parce que ça nécessite
certainement un travail d'analyse et un
travail de réflexion en profondeur de la
part de notre invité même si vous n'avez
pas la mémoire précise de ce qui s'est
passé à l'époque au momentù vous étiez à
votre poste de responsabilité est-ce que
vous êtes avec le recul du temps en
capacité d'analyser aujourd'hui au vu de
cet exemple les faiblesses du système me
les lister les pointer et nous en faire
une note qui permettrait d'éclairer le
rapporteur et le président de la
mission et est-ce que vous ne pensez pas
que jusqu'à aujourd'hui les différents
organismes qui étaient appelés à donner
un avis sur la mise sur le marché de
d'un médicament avec la mesure des
risques que pouvait présenter celui-ci
est-ce que il y a pas eu un travail
beaucoup trop cloisonn des différents
organistmes avec une insuffisance de
transversalité entre eux pour donner un
avis pertinent avant la mise sur le
marché du produit alors on a fait des
progrès je pense mais c'est sans doute
encore à améliorer avec la création de
la Haute Autorité de Santé la hasas et
en regroupant à l'intérieur de la hasas
un certain nombre d'organismes qui
travaillaient chacun de leur côtés avant
donc je voudrais avoir votre sentiment
sur ce
point monsieur le président
je je je je je serais pas
sûr en tous les cas il faudrait que je
me mette à travailler beaucoup et que
éventuellement j'ai j'ai un peu plus de
temps que me laisse le pôle de recherche
et enseignement
supérieur pour pour pour replonger dans
ce dossier je je je suis je je je reste
bon très intéressé par l'organisation
générale du dispositif mais les aspect
particulier de de ce secteur je n'en ai
parlé que de façon générale et je prux
m'en excuser
euh je je je je pense effectivement que
mais votre question me conduit à redire
un peu il ne faut pas que le médicament
ne soit traité qu'à l'agente du
médicament voilà c'est ça revient à
dénoncer l'endogami alors je sais un
argument que que j'entends dans ma
position minoritaire sur la
femmeovigilance on y met à l'InVS il n'y
a pas de compétence de pharmacologie ou
de pharmacie ou bah oui ça c'est c'est
pas un argument excusez-moi si si on
pense qu'il faut que ce soit là on les
crée on les installe d'accord ça fait
pas en un mois bon mais voilà on a et
donc ça ça je je je crois que la le peu
enfin je reste encore à un niveau de
règle générale je pense qu'il faut que
le problème du médicament ne soit pas
envisagé dans une seule et même maison
et que les plusieurs éclairages
bon le le fait que la
hasas je n'ai pas vu fonctionner
puisqu'elle a été
créée plus récemment enfin après que
j'ai quitté le ministère de la
Santé a priori je pense que c'est une
bonne chose mais peut-être
aussi cela renvoie à la coordination des
acteurs à la au rôle du du comité que
vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure et et du
fait pardon le Casa le Casa c'est comme
ça qui s'appelle ça on l'appelle le Casa
c'est facile à retenir d'accord hein
d'accord voilà mais c'est c'est pour le
moment là mais
entre entre deux inconvénients c'est
toujours comme ça que que les décisions
se prennent le premier inconvénient qui
serait de d'avoir tout dans le même tout
le médicament tout ceux qui concne le
médicament dans le même groupe et c'est
c'est un inconvénient euh et
euh le risque d'avoir une coordination
pas assez forte
je je je crois qu'il vaut
mieux faire ce qu'il faut pour avoir une
coordination forte et éviter
l'endogamie dernier
intervenantsieur et après nous
suspendons parce que nous accumulons le
retard je vais je vais essayer d'être
bref vouses rien monsieur monsieur le
professeur vous avez dit tout à l'heure
que il fallait des morts et vous avez
pris l'exemple de la miantee que je
connais bien aussi il fallait des morts
pour qu'on prenne conscience
alors je trouve que c'est
terrible ça met en cause vraiment tout
le dispositif sanitaire de vigilance qui
est en
place c'est c'est très grave ça le met
en cause autrement dit et vous l'avez
dit aussi j'imagine que l'agressivité
des fabricants est supérieur au
dispositif
public vous avez aussi parlé de ça donc
que il me paraît et je trouve
regrettable qu'on l'IT pas vu
avant il me paraît indispensable urgent
qu'on remette en cause tout ce système
et tout le dispositif c'est pour moi la
conclusion que je tire de votre audition
et Monsieur van laorinbert pose une
véritable question qui a été soulevée au
cours des débats qui nous ont précédé
hein c'est que pour mettre un médicament
sur le marché il suffit qu'il y ait une
présomption de rapport bénéfice risque
favorable tandis que pour le retirer il
faut pas de présomption il faut des
certitudes ce qui fait que pour déposer
un médicament en quelques mois l'affaire
est faite mais pour retirer un
médicament il faut des années et et je
pense que pour la miande ça dû être la
même chose hein donc il y a là un
véritable problème auquel il va falloir
répondre et qui pose quand il y a doute
et bien contrairement à ce qui se
passait jusqu'à présent le doute doit
profiter aux malades et non pas à
l'industrie pharmaceutique mais ça c'est
c'est une révolution culturelle qui va
être très difficile à mettre en œuvre
peut-être pas au niveau des structures
mais au niveau des mentalités et ça
c'est le plus compliqué madame la
rapporteur avant de passer voilà est-ce
que vous pensez par rapport par par
rapport à ce risque excusez-moi je ferme
mon portable alors est-ce que vous
pensez que par rapport à à à ce risque
cela est dû aussi au fait ce qui nous a
été dit que lorsque nous avons eu la
sur le viox au fait qu'il y a une
inadéquation entre le modèle qui est un
modèle pastterien sur lequel est
élaboré l'autorisation de mise sur le
marché alors que la population va
prendre ce médicament non pas pour une
pathologie pasteurienne mais à long
terme et que donc le le le modèle est
inadéquat par rapport à la prise du
médicament et enendre un risque
supplémentaire et comme on ne voit pas
qu'en fait l'origine vient du modèle et
bien il y a un risque accru qui fait
éclater le système au grand jour quand
il y a des morts alors tout incidente là
vraent par protection pour Monsieur
Milon merci monsieur le Président non
moi si je veux poser une question je
sais pas du tout si elle est pertinente
en plus mais c'est Monsieur professeur
qui me le dira volontiers je l'autorise
à me le dire je disais que je ne sais
pas si ma question est pertinente mais
c'est la réflexion de Monsieur van
lurenberg qui fait que je suis quand
même tenté de vous la poser euh s'il y a
un siècle en arrière monsieur le
professeur nous avions eu les mêmes
conditions d'analyse des effets
secondairirees des médicaments est-ce
que l'aspirine aurait eu le même sort
que le
Médiator alors euh je peux peux me
retourner là oui ou rour j'aiétais mal
compris plus ça fait déjà une heure
qu'on se regarde oui oui vous pouvez
changer d'horizon je vous
comprends je donne si je comprends votre
re collègue l'impression d'avoir dit
faait qu'il des mors pour qu'on commence
à s'intér santé
publique directeur général de la Santé
àes propos là fusle un ancien bon j'ai
dit que ce qui était important c'est la
quantification mais peut-être que pour
me faire comprendre j'a la
quantification des boutons monsieur le
Président le problème c'est c'est le
microro j'ai l'habitude de regarder les
gens à qui je
parle si effectivement la quantification
ça peut être la quantification
deforescence de bouton voilà c'est pas
le problème c'est pas la mort qui c'est
le fait de le quantifier si
effectivement le l'organe qui suit qui
la pharmacovigilance ou que ce soit voit
que sur X malades qui prennent ce
produit il y a 100 personnes qui en 24
heures ont des boutons partout bah c'est
pareil que si c'est sans mort au point
de vue c'est moins grave mais la
signification c'est ça que je fais Fran
on passe de ah bah oui ce médicament
peut donner des boutons bon puis les
médecins continueront le jour on apprend
que ça don donne 100 boutons enfin 100
personnes atteintent de boutons sur 1000
qui le prennent par exemple on change de
de de logiciel ça c'est une première
chose j'espère que j'ai été clair
deuxièmement euh c'est c'est à la fois
la référence à Pasteur et puis même et
aussi à ce que vous avez dit sur la
facilité avec laquelle on met un
médicament sur le marché je reprends vos
propos monsieur le Président et la
difficulté avec laquelle on le retire
c'est que probablement on ne fait pas
assez de de suivi après am
et et c'est-à-dire que et ça renvoie je
crois que votre collègue quité à qui
j'ai répondu il faut faire des choix de
priorité on peut pas suivre tous les
médicaments de la même façon mais il y
en a o on peut dire quand même on se
pose des questions et à cel on met un
disposition en place de suivi mais mais
pas à mm et qui est par définition
produira des informations plus vite que
l'alerte aléatoire qui viendra pour un
produit qu'on suiva pas et c'est vrai
enfin mais c'est presque
de une position je dirais pas
philosophique mais qui est la place du
médicament dans le système de santé en
général alors cette place de médicament
dans le système de santé en général on
peut le voir de façon économique bon
l'industrie du médicament en France à
telle
part je signale que l'industrie
agroalimentaire c'est 10 fois m en
France ordre de grandeur intéressant bon
mais à contrarion on peut dire le
médicament c'est 10 fois moins que
l'industrie agroalimentaire c'est pas
rien donc il y a un aspect économique
deuxièmement il y a un aspect c'est là
où c'est plus
philosophique le médicament c'est un
recours facile en
santé d'accord on donne que quand on est
malade mais il y a plein
d'exemples où le jour où il y a un
médicament tout ce qui est autre
possibilité thérapeutique en particulier
la prévention passe derrière à tous les
coups ou c'est vrai ou en
1996 moment des trthérapies j'ai une
discussion avec Daniel defer au congrès
de Grenoble et je lui ai dit nous nous
sommes dit on se parie l'un l'autre que
tous les efforts de prévention contre le
sida vont être foutus en l'air par
l'éruption des trithérapies on n pas
moli mais voilà le médicament est pas
seulement aux yeux de l' Industri Farma
au de la société est un recours facile
c'est de comprimés bah il y a beaucoup
de situations de comprimer où c'est plus
facile que des modification de
comportement que de se laver les dents
je sais pas et et cetera voilà que le
médicament est un recours facile dans la
construction de l'effort de santé de nos
sociétés certes promu par de la
publicité certes promu par des intérêts
économiques mais je crois aussi qu'il
faut alle jusque là réfléchir sur
comment on fait pour être et rester en
bonne santé bien alors puisque nous
avons terminé nous allons lever la
séance simplement pour l'aspirine vous
navez pas répondu moi je me permets de
dire
qu'aujourd'hui l'aspirine a quand même
une balance bénéfice risque plus
favorable que celle du médiateur puisque
le médiateur on est bien obligé de
reconnaître qu'il servit à rien donc
donc donc donc donc je crois que la
question était pertinente
ré pas merci Monsieur le Professeur
encore
poures opinions qui bien que
minoritaires sont très fécondes et moi
j'en tiendrai effectivement le plus
grand compte merci
infiniment monsieur le professeur
uber allemand que nous recevons donc
aujourd'hui et
donc le médecin conse
national de la CNAM et c'est à ce titre
que nous l'auditionnons aujourd'hui même
si Madame la rapporteur je
crois pourra faire
état des des fonctions que vous seriez
peut-être appelé à occuper dans un
avenir proche mais je sais que les
journaux racontent pas mal de de fausses
informations et par conséquent il faut
rester très très prudent quoi ce
concerne cette annonce et peut-être que
vous nous en direz plus tout à l'heure
pour le moment nous allons donc vous
interroger sur cette période autour de
98 vous avez été je crois le premier
avec deux de vos collègues d'attirer
l'attention hein de lafsaps sur ce grave
problème de mesusages que
constituait que que qu'on avait pu
obseré à l'occasion de la prescription
du médiateurin j'ai cru d'ailleurs dans
le rapport que euh certains médecins de
c'est pas Besançon c'est Dijon n'est-ce
pas il faut pas confondre c'est des
médecins de de Bourgogne euh porter même
des jugements qui avec leur cul
apparaissent très sensés sur la
véritable utilité de ce médicament à
quoi ça sertin malheureusement à
l'époque c'était pas la question que se
posait lafsaps hein ce sont des médecins
conseil de la sécurité sociale qui sont
posé à l'époque le vrai problème et
j'espère que ça continue aujourd'hui à
se poser les vrais problèmes et j'espère
que demain à son tour lafsaps se posera
enfin les vrais problèmes hein et et
donc je crois que nous sommes bien
partis pour aller dans cette direction
madame euh la rapporteur merci monsieur
le professeur de venir jusqu'au Sénat
comment expliquez-vous monsieur monsieur
le professeur l'absence de de suite
données au courrier que vous aviez
envoyé à à deux de vos confrères une
lettre aussi à l'Agence française du
médicament
insistant sur l'utilisation non
contrôlée d'un produit de structure
amphétaminique dans un but
anorexigène et et quelle procédure
aurait dû alors être engagé avez-vous
par la suite après ce courrier alerter à
nouveau les autorités sanitaires si vous
permettez parce que il me semble que
tout à l'heure enfin je parle sous votre
contrôle lorsque nous avons posé la
question madame Casto elle a dit que il
avait répondu hein à votre courrier
alors effectivement ça et qu'en est-il
exactement je crois que c'est la
question que qu'il faut poser mais il
fallait ajouter ça cette information que
nous venons d'avoir tout à
l'heure monsieur le Président Madame la
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs merci de nous
recevoir de permettre à l'Assurance
Maladie de de s'exprimer par MO
intermédiaire
aujourd'hui cette lettre de 98 a été
adressé dans le cadre de de de contrôle
d'évaluation que nous exerçons à titre
systématique sur des médicaments dont on
a l'impression qu'ils peuvent avoir une
prescription hors à M il n'y a pas que
le médiateur à l'époque il y avait aussi
des médicaments qui servaient au dopage
des médicaments qui servaient à se se
stimuler sous différentes formes des
médicaments utilisés à titre
toxicomaniaque et cetera donc si vous
voulez on était dans des dans des
observations et des études sur plusieurs
médicaments dont le Médiator et euh vous
savez que le médicament est un produit
bien sûr actif que c'est un corps
étranger si j'ai bien compris finalement
quand on absorbe un médicament la
première chose que souhaite faire
l'organisme c'est l'éliminer ça ce n'est
pas moi et avec des tas de métabolisme
et cetera mais pendant son passage on
espère qu'il fait plus de Bénéfic que
des que des faits néfastes et c'est tout
le problème c'est que je crois que je je
répondre d'abord par cela c'est que tout
se joue au niveau du rapport bénéfice
risque et que le bénéfice doit être
supérieur au risque individuellement et
collectivement et ça a été la question à
l'époque et c'est pourquoi nous avons
écrit parce que ce médicament avait un
bénéfice faible il avait un usage qui
n'était pas conforme aux indications
puisqu'il y avait des prescriptions hor
Mme en grand nombre on va dire environ
un/ers des cas selon les différentes
études que l'on avait faites à l'époque
et puis ce médicament avait une analogie
que nous connaissions avec des avec les
amphétaminiques d'une manière générale
et il nous a semblé important d'alerter
les pouvoirs publics sur cette situation
mais vous voyez que ça se joue au niveau
du bénéfice risque un mes usages faut-il
continuer avec un médicament qui est
détourné finalement de son véritable
sort et utilisé comme coupe fin alors
qu'il apporte peu de de Bénéfic et voilà
on proposait une réévaluation de ce
médicament euh
nous avons les informations que vous
avez c'est-à-dire que nous avons observé
dans le cadre du rapport de de Ligas
qu'il y avait eu un projet de réponse
non daté et non signé que nous avons lu
avec intérêt nous n'avons pas retrouvé
de lettres dans nos dans nos archives
mais je dois dire que la
réglementation nous oblige à détruire au
bout de 5 ans toutes nos archives donc
il faut bien voir que il y a des
archives de l'Assurance Maladie de cette
époque dont nous ne disposons plus
et euh parce que évidemment on a on a
fait de de très nombreuses recherches et
et oui et par au fond par par bonne
pratique parce que c'est c'est il y a
des textes qui nous qui qui nous le
demandent ça a été d'ailleurs euh
effectivement pour nous euh une quand on
est dans cette situation on se dit ça
serait ça serait bien bien bien
volontier qu'on retrouve les données
nous ne les avons pas retrouvé si bien
que je ne peux pas répondre formellement
à votre question mais je je ne me
souviens pas avoir eu des réponses alors
comment se fait-il que à lapsap si les
inspecteurs aent retrouvé cette réponse
qui n pas été envoyé ils ont pas les
mêmes contraintes que vous c'est soumis
au même réglementation que nous ah oui
bon en tout cas pour nous c'est très
très c'est très très clair et d'ailleurs
voilà est-ce que vous les avez relancé
euh ultérieurement vous avez relancé
la nous n'avons pas eu de apparemment de
réponse enfin je je ne m'en souviens pas
en tout cas et pas d'écho d'autre
manière non plus donc si vous voulez
pour nous euh nous n'avons pas la
responsabilité de la sécurité d'un
médicament euh n'ayant pas de de de
suite à cette affaire euh B ma fois n on
se dit que les pouvoirs publics
considèrent que il y a pas de risque et
donc on est devant un médicament qui
apporte peu qui manifestement sans doute
n'a pas de risque sinon il y aurait euh
peut-être des réactions et donc nous
nous continuons notre activité la seule
chose à ce moment-là c'est de savoir que
fait-on vis-à-vis du de la prescription
hors AMM puisque c'est là là où
éventuellement il pourrait y avoir un
petit préjudice pour l'assurance maladie
mais on peut pas mettre un gendarme
comme on dit derrière chaque
prescripteur peut-être que je
reviendrait ou si vous me permettez de
faire une parenthèse sur le H AMM à
cion face à ces prescriptions h AMM au
deux choses simples la prescription or
mm est tout à fait possible pour un
médecin ce n'est pas interdit mais elle
est sous sa responsabilité donc on est
bien d'accord mais nous n'avons pas nous
la la la possibilité de contester la
prescription or mm sur des arguments
médicaux puisqu'on ne connaît pas on na
pas d'élément diagnosti comme vous le
savez médicaux dans à notre disposition
donc nous quand on a une prescription
euh de ce médicament on considère
qu'elle est
légitime on remarque simplement quand on
fait des enquêtes spécifiques et je vous
rappelle qu'à l'époque on av'ait pas le
codage des médicaments qu'il y a
effectivement certaines prescription à
RM mais ça demande des études ad hoc il
faut aller rechercher les dossiers voir
convoquer les patients pour savoir
paents qui correspond à l'indication ou
pas c'est donc un travail assz lourd
quand même ces petites ne doit pas
inscrire alors NR alors justement le
médecin doit prescrire NR lorsqu'il
prescrit hors AMM et on avait
pratiquement jamais comme vous le savez
puisqu'il y avait cette situation on l'
retrouvé de de spécification non
remboursable et ceci est une vraie
question qu' faudra peut-être reprendre
c'est d'ailleurs à mon avis une des
questions peut-être qui se pose en amont
de la mise sur le marché d'un médic je
n'ai pas la solution hein mais je pense
qu'aujourd'hui la proportion des
prescriptions hors AMM est est énorme
dans P je quand j'interroge ici ou là
certains pharmacologues certains
avancent des chiffres supérieurs à 50 %
50 % pourquoi c'est considéra pourquoi
je vais vous donner un exemple prenons
une classe la classe des statines ah les
statines vous savez bien que un un
industriel du médicament lorsqu'il
propose son médicamentautorisation de
mise sur le marché c'est dans le cas
cadre d'une indication donnée et il
présente des études qui correspondent à
cette indication il a toute liberté
d'entrer par la porte qu'il souhaite
même s'il a un médicament dont il sait
qu'il a un champ beaucoup plus large
bien et bien il y a des statines qui ont
l'autorisation mise sur le marché pour
la prévention primaire et d'autres qui
l'ont par exemple pour la prévention
secondaire et deux médicaments si je
peux me permettre de donner des
prévention c'est en deuxème intention
c'est ça non prévention secondaire c'est
quand on a déjà une pathologie par
exemple c'est donner des statises quand
on a fait un infarctus du myocarde
d'accord et vous savez que justement
c'est une médication qu'il faut chaque
fois donner lorsqu'on a fait un
infarctus du myocarde c'est de la
prévention secondaire on a déjà la
maladie on évite de rechuter ou de
recommencer et bien deux médicaments les
deux médicaments les plus prescrits dans
notre
pays non pas d'AMM pour la prévention
secondaire donc ces médicaments qui font
plus de la moitié à eux deux et bien
au-delà des des prescriptions dans notre
pays en réalité chaque fois qu'ils sont
prescrits en toute logique après un
infarctus je devrais voir apparaître NR
ah oui et donc on voit bien qu'il y a eu
des assimilations au fil du temps bien
évidemment c'est une classe ça
fonctionne mais on trouve exactement la
même chose pour les inhibiteur de la
pompe à proton et cetera donc le ORM on
se pose la question par rapport au
benforex parce qu'il y a des des
situations àprès de responsabilité
éventuellement et cetera mais mais en
réalité le or mm c'est quelque chose de
très très courant et je crois que je
terminerai là-dessus ma parenthèse mais
je crois que dans un pays qui
euh c'est toujours délicat d'avoir une
règlementation qui n'est pas appliquée
oui parce que on voit bien aujourd'hui
que le c'est c'est d'une certaine
manière inapplicable imaginez qu'on
aille dire à des médecins mais attendez
vous avez prescrit tel médicament tel
statine hors AMM et vous n'avez pas mis
NR il nous dirait mais enfin vous vous
rendez compte médecine c'est déjà
difficile alors si vous ne pouvait pas
organiser quelque chose d'un peu plus
fonctionnel donc c'est c'est un vrai
sujet que le or AMM évidemment il se
pose quand on est en situation de de de
crise comme on connait aujourd'hui et la
deuxème intention quand un médicament
dans son AMM il est indiqué qu'il
devrait être prescrit qu'en 2uxè
intention h ça n'est plus du H s'il est
prescrit en première intention c'est
aussi du H AMM tout à fait mais et là
vous avez pas la mais là on est on est
il y a de temps en temps des prises de
position de la Commission de
transparence dans ce cas-là il y a même
des remboursements qui ne se font que
dans les formes sévères mais pas dans
des formes légères ou modérées pour
certains médicaments mais comment
peut-on le savoir nous n'avons pas de
données médicales moi quand on donne un
médicament à quelqu'un j'ai une
ordonnance avec la prescription mais je
ne sais pas qui est derrière quelle est
sa pathologie et à forceorie si c'est
une forme sévère ou une forme autrement
dit tout ça c'est c'est c'est c'est non
opérationnel on va quand même pas mettre
en cause le sacroin principe de la
liberté de prescription monsieur bien
sûr que non bien sûr mais la question
que vous posez
président est très importante parce que
c'est un des échelons manquants
aujourd'hui de notre dispositif du
médicament parce que on parle de la de
la mise sur le marché qui est une chose
importante on parle de la surveillance
la
pharmacovigilance on parle du
remboursement prix il y a une question
qu'on par service médical rendu il y a
une question qui n'est pas abordée et
qui manque c'est mais quelle est sa
place dans la stratégie thérapeutique
autrement dit c'est le problème de la
hiérarchisation des traitements il y a
effectivement des traitements qui sont
de niveau 1 ou 2 ou TR aujourd'hui tout
ça est utilisé indifféremment et c'est
vrai que nous attendons je me permet de
le dire d'uneune d'une autorité comme la
Haute Autorité de santé qu'il y ait ce
positionnement en terme de hiérarchie
des trait savez qu'on vient de changer
de président je ça peut peut-être vous
rendre optimiste oui mais toute la toute
la ligne du de de mise en œuvre du
médicament dans notre pays est quand
même liée aussi à cet échelon là parce
que on on peut donner aussi un prix
intelligemment à un produit quand on
sait exactement où il se place dans la
stratégie thérapeutique bien sûr mais
aujourd'hui certains pays ont avancé sur
ce sujet par exemple dans des
traitements l'hypertension artérielle il
y a une hiérarchie qui est recommandée
ça veut pas dire qu'on est enfermé
dedans mais au moins qu'il y ait des
repères et on sait quels sont les
hypotenseurs qu'il faut utiliser en
première ligne dans certains pays quel
pays par exemple c'est indifféremment
Nouvelle-Zélande Australie ang
Nouvelle-Zélande c'est intéressant
Angleterre États-Unis parce que
États-Unis sont oup plus puisque c'est
des hatou la NouvelleZélande il font des
choses très bien ils ont ils nont que
deux statines d'ailleurs he il paraît
que les gens s'emportent tout aussi bien
euh madame le rapporteur 12 ans après
vous TER 12 ans après vous élaborez un
rapport 12 ans après le rapport de Ligas
dit
finalement la même chose qui était dite
12 ans avant c'est-à-dire qu'il y a un
problème de mise sur le marché est-il
légitime ne faut-il pas revoir ce
médicament qui apporte peu bien
sûraitil pasès Lepart se poser la
questionou bien sûr mais avant C 12 ans
il y a eu 2009 et votre rapport
préliminaire et comment expliquez-vous
qu'en octobre 2009 plusieurs
interlocuteurs n'étit pas encore
convaincu du lien entre l'exposition au
bainfluorex et la survenue des
valvulopathie comme le précise
Ligas ah parce que je crois
parce que je crois que le doute
bénéficie comme cela a été dit aux
médicaments et pas aux patients parce
que on est quand même dans un monde où
peut-être sans s'en rendre compte on est
séduit par la science les études on va
faire des études complémentaires quand
même pour pour pour savoir parce que là
on a quand même un doute tel tel telle
remontée finalement c'est pas évident
tel c'est il a des billets il faut euh
il faut il faut continuer à voir alors
on se donne du temps on refait des
études et cetera et je crois que c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui qui a un
problème aujourd'hui c'est que il y a
une séduction pour la science pour
pouvoir répondre de manière sûre mais je
crois que si on veut d'abord que le
doute bénéficie au patient il faut à un
moment donné devant certains signaux
être pragmatique et à ce moment-là
stopper ce qui est très séduisant
c'est-à-dire de connaître la vérité pour
prendre des décisions qui
qui sont des décisions d'ordre humaine
et un médecin c'est cela
individuellement c'est bien sûr
collectivement lorsquon est dans des
décisions des pouvoirs publics aidés par
des agences ou des commissions on voit
bien que
là le le il y a une une séduction pour
aller toujours plus loin et on en oublie
finalement de manière très très simple
et très pragmatique de dire mais écoutez
mais en attendant aujourd'hui on a
suffisamment d'indicateurs pour pouvoir
peut-être prendre une décision qui peut
être que suspensive euh si c'est
possible he je sais que la
réglementation est compliquée il faudra
peut-être regarder ces choseslà mais
véritablement c'est cela le fond du
problème c'est
que on voit bien com on est dans des
commissions d'experts des personnes qui
réfléchissent qui pensent qui analysent
tout d'un coup comme il y a une ligne de
responsabilité qui va pas jusqu'à la
décision pragmatique opérationnelle pour
pour pour pour pour pour le pays ça
fonctionne pas à un moment donné on s'en
rend compte alors c'est bien pour ça
c'est bien pour cela que euh il y a deux
choses qu'il faut dire ici c'est que je
pense qu'il y a un problème au niveau de
la de l'accueil des alertes et même des
petites alertes ça alors ça je crois que
c'est quelque chose qui culturellement
n'est peut-être pas encore saisi mais
une alerte il y a très peu de chance
qu'un accident qu'un effet indésirable
soit déclaré vous savez que de bonnes
études disent qu'au fond il y a 5 % de
chance non mais prenons simpleement
ement une fois un accident qui arrivera
une fois sur 1000 ce qui est ce qui ce
qui est déjà relativement fréquent mais
5 % d'une fois sur 1000 vous voyez que
ça vous fait 5 fois sur 100000 ça veut
dire que quand vous voyez apparaître le
clignotant ah mais il faut le prendre
très très au sérieux parce qu'en réalité
il est il est peut-être le l'arbre qui
est qui est en avant d'une petite forêt
derrière or on voit bien que c'est c'est
pas c'est pas comme ça que nous avons
fonctionné il y a toujours le doute oui
mais il avait telle pathologie ça doit
être lié à telle pathologie c'est encore
pire lorsqu'on ne sait pas que le le
produit en question peut donner des
effets secondaires mais là on avait
quand même des analogie avec d'autres
produits donc je pense que déjà là les
les les radars ne sont pas assez
sensibles sur les petites alertes et ça
il faut vraiment à mon avis justement il
faut que le doute bénéficie au patients
dans cette affaire là voilà et qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé en 2009 c'est
que nous n'avions jamais entendu parler
des effets secondaire du Médiator ou à
l'assurance maladie avant le 12 octobre
2009 et le 12 octobre 2009 vous
connaissez l'affaire un de nos personnes
qui travaillent à laacnam dans un COC
entend parler de cela et on lui dit mais
est-ce que sur vos bases de données et
cetera vous ne pouvez pas regarder mais
c'est là où c'est intéressant parce
qu'effectivement aujourd'hui nous avons
des bases de données qui peuvent
éventuellement pas toujours mais dans le
cas particulier ça a bien fonctionner
pouvoir répondre à des questions qui
peuvent être suscité par des toutes
petites alertes et c'est là où on voit
s'organiser le complément entre une
pharmacovigilance qui est la remontée
d'éléments cliniquees et puis l'usage de
base de données qui peuvent
éventuellement confirmer ou infirmer le
clignotant et dans le cas particulier ça
a permis de le
confirmer l'étude
était à partir du moment où vous
possédez la base de données bien entendu
vous la possédez depuis quand depuis
alors justement important parce qu'on
entend dire beaucoup de choses sur ce
sujet nous
possédons l'exhaustivité des données de
prescription sur le sniram depuis 2005
donc en 2005 vous pouviez faire une
étude sur sur le 2005 je peux commencer
à faire le rapport entre un médicament
et ces conséquences par exemple en terme
de complication cardiaque parce que
avant nous avions depuis 2000 la base
des médicaments mais nous n'avions pas
les autres donné donc on pouvait pas
faire de lien donc en 2005 vous pouviez
le faire ce que vous avez fait en 2008
je ne pouvais pas en 2005 vous allez
voir pourquoi parce qu'en 2005 je
possède les données de prescription de
tous les bénéficiaires du régime
général pour les prescriptions
ambulatoires le chaînage
opérationnel avec l'hôpital c'est que
depuis 2009 ah et oui il faut voir que
c'est très récent c'est que le chaînage
entre le sniram et le PMSI et donc sur
une affaire comme celle-là où beaucoup
de choses se passent à l'intérieur
l'hôpital pour les interventions
valvulopathie c'est pas toujours des des
hôpitaux publics mais enfin c'était
souvent le cas donc il faut bien voir VO
qu'en réalité c'est très récent d'accord
le fait c'est pour ça que ça tombe ça
tombe et on parlera peut-être tout à
l'heure mais je termine justement sur
ces dates des bases de données parce que
c'est je crois que c'est
important pour pouvoir chaîner ensuite
avec les décès c'est que depuis juillet
2009 donc il faut bien voir que là donc
pour le vioc c'était pas possible ah non
non c'est on a les décès très très
récemment comm autrement dit on est dans
une situation où où c'était mur pour
pouvoir effectivement répondre parce que
des personnes effectivement disent mais
pourquoi vous voulez pas faire avant
mais mais avant de toute façonétait si
vous n'aviez pas été prêt il faut bien
voir que ça s'est fait très rapidement
aussi parce qu'on était dans des
conditions favorables on avait des
Cortes diabétiques qui étaient prêtes
puisqu'on suit de très près vous savez
cette pathologie et donc c'est les bases
de données de diabétique puisque c'est
la première étude est faite sur 1
million diabétique de 2006 comme vous le
savez donc la base était prête on avait
les médicaments éventuellement en
question le benfuorex et on nous disait
regardez les valvulopathies donc on
avait tous les éléments très objec pour
pouvoir avancer vite mais il faut pas
croire que toute étude pourrait se faire
dans les mêmes délais et aussi peut-être
avec la même facilité donnéôpit 2009 dit
conduit donc la même année à élaborer le
rapport puisque je constate que votre
rapport est élaboré le 27 octobre 2009
vous l'avez fait donc à partir des bases
de données que vous aviez exactement
donc très rapidement très rapidement
puisquon est prévenu le 12 octobre et on
répond très vite quasiment un mois demi
après mais pourquoi parce effectivement
ce que je viens de dire est important on
était prêt avec la base de données des
diabétiques sinon ça aurait pris un
petit peu plus de de délis on était
vraiment dans des conditions extrêmement
favorables pour répondre à la
sollicitation qui nous a ce genre
d'étude vous comptez le faire pour
d'autres médicaments est-ce que vous en
avez l'initiative ou il faut attendre
une commande de
lafsaps alors 77 médicament alors ça
c'est une question c'est une question
qui est importante et qui cette fois-ci
entre un petit peu dans peut-être dans
comment nous pouvons améliorer le le
système
c'est
qu'effectivement aujourd'hui on est en
mesure peut-être qu'il y en a d'autres
aussi mais nous sommes en mesure de
répondre à des demande des
agences quel qu'ell soit lafs ça peut
être aussi l'InVS enfin l'Institut de
veille sanitaire pour lorsqu'ils ont un
clignotant ou une demande ou une
suspicion des faets secondaires enfin
des faits indésirables on peut
éventuellement répondre à partir de nos
bases de données si la question qui est
posée correspond à nos
fautil qu'on vous en fasse la demande
voilà et je pense que c'est important
que ce soit les agences qui fassent la
demande parce que vous voyez bien si
c'était quelque chose qui était fait
uniquement par l'assurance maladie on
dirait mais l'assurance alors un conflit
d'intérêt dans l'autre sens va regarder
où ça l'intéresse le médicament coûteux
enfin on entendrait un petit peu tout
non c'est très important que ça soit les
pouvoirs publics et aujourd'hui nous
sommes en possibilité d'avoir une
expertise publique de très très haut
niveau euh par des tas de dispositifs
dont les bases de données qui arrivent à
maturité mais que ce soit les agences
c'est dire les pouvoirs public ou la
délégation qui fait de faire la demande
comme ça c'est ni les les professionnels
les industriels ni des financeurs c'est
les pouvoirs publics qui disent écoutez
nous avons besoin de savoir ce qu'il en
est sur ce produit pouvez-vous nous
répondre pou répondre à cette question
nous avons engagé ce
processus je nous avons créé une un pôle
spécifique pour pouvoir répondre à ces
questions parce par que c'est pas facile
de de faire des requêtes sur nos bases
de données qui sont gigantesques comme
vous le savez qui demandent une grosse
expertise parce que elles sont basées
sur la réglementation du remboursement
donc c'est pas des études qui sont
faites d'abord à destiné épidémiologique
c'est un produit secondaire la
pharmacoépidémiologie de de de ces bases
et il faut très très bien les connaître
pour les exploiter euh nous nous
renforçons notre pôle justement pour
pouvoir répondre à ces demandes
maintenant et dans l'avenir mais d'ors
et déjà nous avons fait une convention
avec l'Institut de veille sanitaire pour
répondre à leur le demande quant à leur
responsabilité nous réfléchissons à une
convention avec lafsaps lasaps vous a
demandé une convention nousous nous
avons commencé à réfléchir à la
convention qui pourrait entre lafsaps et
nous mais voilà le futur directeur je
pense le
lea vous verrez vous verrez avec lui
hein voilà d'accord bien est-ce que vous
avez été en contact lorsque vous avez
élaboré votre premier courrier avec le
Centre régional de de pharmacovigilance
de de Besançon d'autant que vous êtes
professeur de santé publique à à
Besançon sentre qui a été le premier à
mettre en en
exerg le danger de la consommation du du
Médiator oui alors j'ai vu ça dans le
rapport que ce que ce comité c'est pour
ça qu'on pose la question que ce comité
régional avait été sur le sujet très tôt
et a sollicité après pour faire des
études spécifiques je connais
euh je connaissais à l'époque je
connaissais bien monsieur professeur
Bechtel qui était le pharmacologue de de
de l'époque et en retrait maintenant euh
nous nous rencontrions ici ou là mais
nous n'avons jamais évoqué ce sujet
ensemble jamais voilà en
97 je suis nommé ici à Paris je passe le
clair de Mont temps à Paris7
vousz depuis 91 puisque je je je je
m'occupais du département santé publique
à laacnam dès 91 nommé médecin conseil
national en 97
donc détacher de mes fonctions
hospitalières à l'acnam donc j'avais des
fonctions universitaires que j'ai
toujours à la faculté de médecine de
Besançon mais je ne suis plus au sein du
du CHU où exerçait monsieur bestchtel à
l'époque et c'est vrai que nous n'avons
jamais évoqué cette question dans dans
mon
souvenir madame l'intérêt général à à
réévaluer le service médical rendu à à
empêché son mésugeage à donné une
réponse efficace au signalement de de de
pharmacovigilance a-t-elle été
sous-estimée par par rapport au aux
intérêts des des
laboratoires et qui est responsable
selon vous des dysfonctionnements
révélés par le rapport de
Ligas est-ce que on on a posé la même
question puisquon on arrive aussi à une
deuxième série de questions puisque
notre mission concerne non seulement le
Médiator mais l'évaluation et le
contrôle du médicament faut-il déplorer
aussi la DISP la dispersion des des
instances d'autorisation et de contrôle
ayant entraîné une diluion des
responsabilités
oui alors c'est une vraie question la
question des
responsabilités pour être simple je
crois qu'il y a d'abord et de façon
importante si l'on regarde le sujet des
responsabilités la responsabilité du
laboratoire pour des raisons qui ont été
décrites mais pour une raison finalement
fort simple c'est que le laboratoire à
l'intégralité des informations sur son
médicament y compris les informations
internationales y compris ce que le
positionnement de certains pays par
rapport à leurs produits on a vu encore
récemment que la Belgique s'était
prononcé très tôtou donc il faut voir
que toute l'info il y en a peut-être
d'autres oui toute l'info est possédé
par le laboratoire a-t-elle donné aussi
cette info à ceux qui ont jugé d'un
produit c'est une question euh et donc
s'il faut parler des responsabilités je
DIRIS tout d'abord pour des certain
nombre de raisons que nous connaissons
mais notamment celle-ci il y a une
responsabilité forte du laboratoire
c'est
pourquoi je me permets de le dire à cet
instant l'assurance maladie dans son
ensemble c'est-à-dire le régime général
le le RSI la MSA ont décidé de porter
plainte notamment pour tromperie
aggravé afin que la justice puisse
trancher sur la responsabilité réelle du
labor atoire et que finalement
l'assurance maladie donc les citoyens
soit de dédommager des conséquences
multiples de cette affaire parce qu'il y
a eu des remboursements de médicaments
dont il semble bien qu'ils ne sont plus
très légitimes au moins depuis
1999 il y a la prise en charge des
conséquences quand vous dites 99 c'est
vous vous référez je me réfère au
rapport de Ligas au rapport de Ligas qui
dit qu'en 1999 on savait que à ce
moment-là le médicament il y avait
suffisamment d'éléments pour réaliser le
retrait du médicament ils sont assz
clairion à l'avis de la commission de
transparence he c'est pas non non c'est
je me je me réfère au au rapport de
liigas
d'accord donc il y a le fait d'avoir
bien sûr pris en charge
le le produit 220 millions d'euros de
remboursé et puis les conséquences
sanitaires pour les personnes qui ont eu
des atteintes valvulaires on parle des
décès mais il y a beaucoup
d'hospitalisations beaucoup de
chirurgies sous circulation
extracorporelle et puis aujourd'hui des
euh bien sûr enfin ça sera pris en
charge dans d'autres circonstances mais
le rappel des patients et les
conséquences mais en tout cas en ce qui
concerne la tromperie aggravée nous
allons déposer plainte avec ce chef
alors pour ce qui est des autres
responsabilité on est manifestement
devant un éclatement des responsabilités
et qui est lié comme vous l'avez dit
Madame au à la segmentation de notre
système et très très clairement euh
les les différents niveaux de
responsabilité ne fonctionnent pas
ensemble et en coordination et c'est un
vrai sujet je pense qu' une
responsabilité pour ce pour cette la
situation particulière du benfuorx au
niveau de l'autorisation de mise sur le
marché la première responsabilité
fallait-il prendre une une décision de
de d'autorisation de mise sur le marché
c'est une décision qui est toujours très
importante et dans cette décision le
doute doit bénéficier au patients je
suis un fervant des penseur de la
gestion du risque d'amont c'est-à-dire
si quelque chose n'est pas très
nécessaire dans le système de soins il
faut mieux agir en amont donc
éventuellement ne pas prendre en charge
un médicament plutôt que de courir
derrière après pendant des années en
terme de contrôle de surveillance
d'évaluation quand le bénéfice est très
faible on est bien d'accord et donc on
se simplifie quand même fortement la vie
en en complication quand on voit
qu'elles arrivent ou en prescription au
Ramm ou en bruit de fond avec des
produits qui n'ont peut-être pas une
très très grande valeur ajoutée je suis
un peu un peu un un peu rapide mais la
la la première responsabilité c'est au
niveau de la MM y compris dans cette
affaire deuxièmement euh je crois que
quand il y a des éléments nouveaux il
faut savoir revoir un produit on a parlé
de la pharmacovigilance et des signaux
faibles qu'il faut considérer comme très
très fort et est est essentiel à à
capter et à regarder de près je crois
qu'il y a aussi parallèlement sur ce
point-là aussi le fait qu'on était isolé
en Europe euh sur le plan de la la la
commercialisation de ce produit ça
aurait dû quand même interroger
sérieusement alors je sais que et et
pourquoi votre avis on on était les
seuls pratiquement à consommer du
Médiator si on excepte
évidemmentagneitalie on voit bien que la
prise de Malte et la grèe que la prise
de décision de retrait d'un
médicament n'est pas facile notamment
dans notre contexte réglementaire c'est
une prise de risque c'est clair c'est
une prise de risque et on voit comment
éventuellement une agence peut peut peut
être
parfois
peut-être un peu plus ilanime en
craignant des procédures derrière mais
c'est là
où la décision doit bénéficier au
patients et non au laboratoire alors qui
est le
client d'une agence c'est les
industriels ou c'est la sécurité des
Français elle est français ça c'est une
vraie question et donc on voit bien que
dans certains pays on a mis le patient
monsieur le ministreu on a mis le
patient avant et dans d'autres pays
peut-être que ça été moins net parce
qu'il peut y avoir des enjeux
économiques et que dans d'autres pays
les enjeux économiques sont moindres il
faut bien voir que c'est pas des
questions faciles je suis pas en train
de mais mais la situation c'est quand
même celle-là c'est que c'est une
décision difficile il y a un risque
toujours dans une décision une décision
peut être une décision simplement de
suspension mais effectivement il y a
peut-être culturellement à changer notre
notre positionnement par rapport à
toutes ces affaires et je vois bien que
l'éclatement des des des décisions sur
le médicament alors il y a des
commissions d'AMM des commissions de
transparence des commissions de de de
pharmacovigilance tout ça ne communique
pas beaucoup d'ailleurs des fois c'est
un peu en opposition de phase si on lit
chose une commission qui dit ça mais
l'autre dit non je suis pas d'accord ce
qui veut dire qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
ça veut dire qu'il y a trop deusion et
qu'il faut recentrer une expertise
beaucoup plus forte sur la vie du
médicament en permanence à l'instant T
un médicament ça rentre à un moment
donné dans le processus du système de
soin ça peut en sortir mais quand il est
là il faut le surveiller chaque jour
c'est-à-dire que son rapport bénéfice
ris va changer en fonction de ce que
l'on capte donc il peut changer mais
aussi son positionnement dans la
hiérarchie des traitements c'est pour ça
que j'insistais tout à l'heure autrement
dit il faut que les personnes qui
s'occupent de médicaments un moment
donné se retrouve pour voir sa vie en
totalité il n'y a pas eu de
transversalité dans cette affaire vous
vous vous
on le voit bien et moi je pense que il
faut donc faire un processus
d'intégration des informations et aussi
des d'intégration des acteurs il faut
qu'ils soient moins nombreux beaucoup
plus
responsable ça veut donc dire quoi ça
veut donc dire qu'il faut qu'il soiit
indépendant des industriels c'est c'est
les les confl mais c'est je vais vous
dire je crois très fortement que on peut
pendant 4 ou 5 an de son existence être
dans une structure comme celle-là quand
on a un hospital universitaire par
exemple que c'est un travail absolument
passionnant euh et qu'au lieu de
dépendre éventuellement de rémunération
des industriels que ce soit les pouvoirs
publics qui rémunèent ces gens à hauteur
de ce qu'il le seraiit autrement mais
ils font un travail passionnant beaucoup
plus riche parce que attention on entend
des fois des arguments que de
d'accompagner pendant le même temps un
ou deux essais thérapeutiques avec un
laboratoire parce que ça à la limite ça
ça ne nourrit pas automatiquement
intellectuellement votre homme vous
comprenez je je vous voyez que être en
situation au quotidien quasiment
d'analyser des données de
pharmacoépidémiologie des essais
thérapeutiques des données de
pharmacovigilance mais je peux vous dire
que vous travaillez drôlement et vous
êtes très très très compétent et vous
avez euh devant vous un serviteur qui
qui qui n'exerce plus directement avec
des mal des malades individueles mais
qui est très intéressé par le médicament
et qui et qui a l'impression de de de de
connaître un petit peu le sujet
par je dis très simplement parce que
vous savez que sur le ribonaban je suis
intervenu très fortement et que d'emblé
j'ai j'ai j'ai j'ai questionné la
commission de transparence sur ce
produit lorsqu'il a été mis sur le
marché j'ai dit mais écoutez il y a un
certain nombre de points qui qui qui me
pose question c'est quand vous avez un
médicament qui qui qui agit au niveau du
cerveau sur des récepteurs et qui tout
d'un coup montrent des effets
secondaires de type problèmes
psychiatrique suicide et dans dans les
essais même s'ils sont peu nombreux vous
dites attention je suis devant un vrai
sujet surtout si on va en faire un
blockbuster donc et et et et donc j'ai
écrit j'ai écrit à la Commission de
transparence pour leur dire j'ai des
doutes sur cette sur sur ce médicament
je l'ai dit au laboratoire d'ailleurs
faites attention il faut mieux entrer
par une petite porte parce qu'il y a
quand même danger pour un bénéfice qui
n'était pas
gigantesque bien on vous a répondu et
bien
non on m'a pas répondu et j'ai j'ai je
je crois qu'on n pas été très content de
mon intervention non de faire pression
sur la Commission de transparence non ça
se fait pas ah bon donc tout ça pour
vous dire que un mois
F disait la mme chose ausis et que
toutun coup un petit pe changer pour
autant le médicament est rest
commercialisé an mais vousir que c'est
intéressant l'ffaire c'est qu' bout d'un
an j'ai renvoyé un courrier au directeur
général de la Santé
et Monsieur Laur
de président de la Haute Autorité de
Santé pour leur dire voilà un médicament
qui a des effets secondaires dangereux
qui entraînent des suicides qu'il faut
surtout ne pas donner à des personnes
qui sont dépressifes je me permets de
vous informer qu'il y a plus de 10 % sur
nos bases de données des personnes qui
prennent du rimonaban qui ont
parallèlement des antidépresseurs et je
pense qu'il y a un vrai sujet voilà et
quelques semaines après le médicament ét
retiré comme vous le
savez monre bien la logique de tout mais
il faut être très déterminé quand on et
donc c'est pas c'est pas parce que on
travaille scientifiquement
j'insiste peut-être un peu trop non non
allez à longueur de journée avec des
industriels que que que que on est
automatiquement compétent et que
d'autres personnes ne seraient pas
compétentes parce qu'on entend des fois
des choses un petit peu rapides dans sur
cette situation là moi je crois que des
personnes qui donneraient quelques
années de leur existence comme expert de
très très haut niveau dans une agence
mais avec des responsabilités recentré
et portant la vie du médicament dans
toutes ces dimensions et alertant euh
les
autorités au moment opportun ou en
prenant des décisions voilà parce que un
moment donné il faut que quelqu'un
prenne des décisions mais on navait pas
de nœud décisionnel dans cette affaire
la la la ligne décisionnelle n'existait
pas me semble-t-il suffisamment
fortement je ne suis pas en train de
porter des critiques à à un métier qui
est extrêmement difficile entendez-moi
bien et d'ailleurs je profite si vous
permettez de dire une chose entre
parenthèses parce que sinon je la dirai
pas et je souhaite la dire euh oui il
faut corriger le tir
oui il faut améliorer la situation mais
je pense que il ne faudrait pas oublier
tout ce qui a été fait précédemment et
on a quand même beaucoup progressé au
cours de de toutes ces années on a
construit des dispositifs bon là on est
devant une situation on voit que il y a
une une faille mais je pense que il ne
faudrait pas oublier tout ce qui a déjà
été fait et il faut mais mais bien vous
en êtes convaincu mais je me permets de
le dire parce que il faut pas être trop
brutal il y a des personnes qu'on entend
on considère qu'il faut tout
reconstruire à zéro pas du tout pas du
tout justement justement profitons de
enfin ce sont des nouveaux convertis si
vous voulez c'est pas effectivement il
vont tout de suite je veux pas être trop
long mais mais mais mais c'est vrai
qu'il faut qu'on prenne très au sérieux
les conséquences de cette crise mais
mais continuons à construire ou oui on
sait où il faut aller maintenant très
bien merci Madame la rapporteur je sais
pas comment il faut vous nommer à
l'instant où je vais vous poser cette
question mais faut-il réformer
l'fsfs et et que pensez-vous du projet
de direction bicéphale de l'agence de la
réforme de la composition des
commissions de celle du système de
financement annoncé par le
gouvernement première question deuxè
question comment améliorer la réactivité
des autorités publiques au plus haut
niveau dans ce domaine tant au niveau
des
signalements au niveau des expertises
vous avez un petit peu répondu et au
niveau décisionnel comment par exemple
améliorer les mesures de suspension de
retrait améliorer la transparence et le
pluralisme alors j'ai j'ai j'ai apporté
quelques réponses peut-être trop trop
trop vite sur cette question je pense
que les les les propositions qui sont
faites sont
euh les propositions qui sont faites
sont très intéressantes notamment euh je
pense une direction bicéphale
euh parce que c'est une
c'est une
structure difficile que l'agence de
française de sécurité sanitaire des
produits de santé il y a énormément de
champs à couvrir et il y a manifestement
des des dimensions qui sont des
dimensions d'ordre administrative
juridique très très lourde et puis des
dimensions plutôt d'ordre médicale et
scientifique et je pense qu' un binôme
est une bonne chose d'autant plus
que j'en suis et je devrais dire nous en
sommes convaincus
expérimentalement Frédéric vanrockegem
et moi-même
puisque nous nous nous avons finalement
comme vous le savez
constituer voilà une sorte de binôme la
tête de de de la caisse
nationaleassurance maladie et d'ailleurs
dans la logique fondu les services
médicaux et administratifs qui étaient
très très séparés au moins au niveau de
de laacnam c'est encore à venir
peut-être encore de manière plus aboutie
je ne sais pas sur au niveau du réseau
mais je pense pense que à la tête
d'institution de de cet ordre un binôme
est très peut très très bien fonctionner
et à son utilité justement si les
décisions doivent être prises à un
moment donné par par une personne en
ayant le background suffisant pour
pouvoir la la prendre alors après
l'ordre de presséance mais mais un
binôme me paraît une option
intéressante je pense que il y a des
hypothèses
qui vont dans le sens d'un d'un
éclatement de certaines responsabilités
je pense par exemple à la la
pharmacovigilance et tout
ça en se disant mais la vigilance d'un
côté et puis domaine dans moi je pense
qu'il faut j'aurais plutôt tance en tout
cas il faut réfléchir à cette
possibilité je crois qu'il faudrait
plutôt recentrer les responsabilités il
faut mettre de la il faut mettre de de
l'intégration dans les informations et
il faut mettre de la coordination dans
les décisions sur le médicament donc moi
je verrai plutôt un lieu où on porte
l'ensemble des responsabilité du
médicament à un moment donné oui alors
après que les outils puissent être
délégués de pharmacovigilance c'est une
structure une logistique lourde mais il
faut qu'à un moment donné il y ait des
personnes qui aient la vision globale
sur la situation d'un médicament à un
moment donné et qui a pas la la
pharmacovigilance d'un côté des
renouvellements d'AMM de l'autre en
enfin je je je pense qu'il faut
recentrer euh tout ça sur une une une
quelque chose de plus coordonné donc
vous êtes pour la réintégration de la
commission moi je pense qu'il faut des
des des des il faut une ligne claire de
responsabilité en recentrant euh les
responsabilités en recentrant les
experts et bien sûr en en les valorisant
parce qu'on aura pas une une cellule de
ce type là avec des experts si on les
valorise pas je parle pas uniquement
valorisation financière monsieur le
président et vous le savez très bien
quand je parle des experts je parle
aussi de la valorisation universitaire
oui parce qu'il faut que évidemment euh
cette activité puisse compter dans la
vie universitaire parce que sinon
effectivement c'est une pénalité pour le
pour pour l'impétrant et dédommager euh
les hôpitaux aussi du temps que les P
phpu passent à lafsap ce qui n'est pas
le cas à l'heure actuelle par exemple
Moon je pense qu'il faudrait qu'il y a
beaucoup plus de l'attitude pour pouvoir
prendre des décisions sur un médicament
euh lorsqu'on a des doutes j'ai euh mais
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui la réglementation
le permet je ne le sais pas la
réglementation est est assez lourde
assez protectrice je je je pense des
industriels du médicament et il faut
certainement rétablir un peu des
équilibres il faut que si on on met en
place un dispositif où les personnes
sont responsabilisées il faut qu'ell
puissent agir et il faut qu'elleell
puisse en toute liberté à un moment
donné proposer la suspension ou l'arrêt
provisoire ou le retrait des médicament
parce que si si on a des étanarmes parce
que ça va être trop lourd ça va être
procédural je je pense qu'il alors
est-ce que la réglementation peut être
facilement modifiée je ne sais pas c'est
vrai que beaucoup de vous le savez mieux
que mieux que nous que beaucoup de
choses se passent au niveau européen
pour autant je vois que des pays se sont
se sont autorisés de retirer des
médicaments donc ça doit être possible
mais ça je pense qu'il faut redonner de
la de la souplesse à ceux qui ont une
responsabilité sur le dispositif général
de régulation du médicament c'est
fondamental parce que sinon nous sommes
aujourd'hui plutôt un peu dans un
déséquilibre au profit des des
industriels et je vais vous dire les
industriels moi je les admire beaucoup
je parle en général là pas en train de
parler d'un laboratoire particulier ils
sont très professionnels monsieur le
Président et vous le savez et je dis
toujours autour de moi et notamment en
interne auprès de mes services médicaux
soyons aussi bon que soyons de grands
professionnels de l'évaluation du contrô
et nous commençons à l'être parce qu'on
a des outils comme les bases de données
parce qu'on a des forces sur le terrain
qui nous permettent d'agir je pense au
délégués de l'assurance maladie aux
entretiens confraternels que nous
faisons et ceci évidemment a eu des
réactions puisque vous savez on a eu des
procès retentissants évidemment de la
part de certains laboratoires qui
considéraent qu'on allait au-delà de nos
prérogatifes dans l'a par exemple dans
l'Aude vous savez que avec un
laboratoire tout ça était justusqu'en
cassation et nous avons gagné que on
peut pas un petit laboratoire comme
celui de ser petit laboratoire et donc
si vous V
je rêve un jour d'être un grand
professionnel comme les industriels du
médicament nous sommes en
chemin non mais emment mais ça ça veut
dire quand même en quittant le côté un
peu peut-être humoristique de de la
manière dont on s'exprime c'est que
c'est que c'est je je parle du
professionnalisme des pouvoirs publics
oui oui et je pens avait été un peu
avait été professionnel monsieur le
professeur comment le Sénat de son côté
parle des pouvoirs public avait été
professionnel puisque suite à l'affaire
du viox le Sénat avait élaboré en 2006
un rapport qui est intitulé restaurer la
confianceouver qu'on a redécouvert
récemment puisque moi j'ai lu les
conclusions du rapport de Ligas et je
m'aperçois que nos conclusions étai
élaboré en 2006 et je m'étonne
parallèlement que les pouvoirs publics
n'ai pas essayé de mettre en place un
certain nombre de mesures concrètes que
nous proposions à l'époque alors c'est
un petit peu la dernière questionant
plus à l'époque c'était monsieur
Bertrand qui était déjà ministre de la
Santé enfin peut-être que j'aurais pas
dû dire ça alors c'était en tout cas la
question que je voulais vous poser aussi
parce que ça me paraît important vous en
avez parlé euh après cette affaire euh
la nécessité de réorganisé aussi euh
comment aussi restaurer la confiance
vis-à-vis des médicaments tout à fait
pour le patient parce que c'est aussi
important qui qu'il ne soit plus qu'il
n'occulte plus le médicament certains
peuvent avoir cette réaction
mais je pense qu'il faut euh dans ce
cadre-là c'est pas mais redonner de la
de
la de la force d'intervention au pouvoir
public parce que la confiance ça passera
aussi par les pouvoir public je dis ça à
propos par exemple des bases de données
il peut y avoir des conflits d'intérêts
sur ces bases de données vous savez que
certains veulent les utiliser notamment
des organismes à but lucratif moi je
pense qu'aujourd'hui les pouvoirs
publics ont les moyens de répondre à des
questions qui se pose à notre société
sur le poste AMM et euh euh voilà je je
je je crois qu'il faut vraiment qu'on
prenne le le le le le le destin de ce
qui se passe en terme de prescription
dans notre pays en main et que c'est une
manière d'être transparent vis-à-vis du
public et de dire voilà la situation
voilà ce qui se passe nous l'observons
nous vous tenons informés j'ai compris
qu'on voulait aussi introduire des
représentants ici ou là dans différents
organismes tout ça est très très bien
mais faisons attention de pas rebasculer
dans des conflits d'intérêts et de
toujours laisser peut-être dans la même
main très professionn je reconnais mais
les choses déjà avoir finalement une
grande liberté sur le
préamm je je pense que les pouvoirs
publics ont beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup à
faire j'ai lu avec intérêt ce rapport
que vous évoquez parce que je l'U aussi
effectivement je vois qu'il y a beaucoup
de choses qui étaient dites à l'époque y
a des bonnes choses même même même ce
fait le président Me trompera pas que ce
serait bien aussi si éventuellement la
la assurance maladie avait la
possibilité de dérembourser les
médicaments ce qu'elle n'a pas
aujourd'huia été évoqué écoutez je vais
vous dire je vais vous dire moi dans ce
rapport de 2005 j'étais commissaire et
j'avais fait donc des propositions et
qui consistait à confier à l'assurance
maladie le soin de fixer le prix des
médicaments et ça me semble être une
évolution à laquelle il nous sera je
crois dans les années qui viennent
difficile d'échapper quoi en associant
aussi les assurances complémentaires
bien évidemment hein mais une première
marche pourrait être d'avoir au moins la
parité au niveau du comité économique
des produits de santé ce qui n'est pas
le cas aujourd'hui aujourd'hui nous
sommes minoritaires les les assurances
obligatoires et complémentaires en
face et donc je pense que voilà il y a
peut-être des des des j'étais pour la
suppression P et simple duou oui ce qui
est peut-être plus radical et plus
efficace et qui évite peut-être de
passer par cette étape transitoire qui
n'est pas forcément nécessaire quoi bien
euh messieurs les commissaires vous avez
sûrement des questions je vois monsieur
euh tiens j oui moi je je voulais
monsieur le Président bon je commençais
à me dire si j'allais partir parce que
je voyais que le dialogue se faisait
dans ce sens et et nous on est là vous
regardez
un très beau discours de Monsieur
allemand
qui met bien en valeur tout ce qu'il
veut faire et tout ce que s'il nous dit
pas seulement pourquoi il a mis tant de
temps ou il s'est contenté
en en 98 je crois de de ne pas aller
au-delà de la simple lettre alors qu'il
l'a fait par ailleurs pour un autre
médicament d'autant que vous étiez trois
en plus puisquil y av TR caisses donc je
crois que tout ce que vous dites c'est
très
séduisant c'est des
ilaka hein alors en aurez-vous le la
possibilité je ne sais mais il y a quand
même il faut quand même ne pas occulter
la pression du laboratoire faut pas
quand même nous raconter d'histoire ça
s'est pas passé comme ça hein il y a eu
la pression du laboratoire comme il y a
les pression des laboratoires comme sur
les médecins il y a l' pression des
visiteurs médicaux et ETTI quanti hein
donc je crois que c'est c'est presque
c'est une autre histoire qu'il faut
qu'il faut écrire si on veut revenir sur
sur tout cela autrement ça recommencera
parce que bon bah la pression continuera
il y a
l'économie du médicament et puis a les
différentes pressions connait pas
seulement d'ailleurs vis-à-vis de la
pharmacie et dans bien d'utres domaines
donc moi j'ai écouté bon religieusement
votre dialogue avec le président et avec
le le rapporteur bon ben écoutez on va
voir hein mais j'ai cru à un moment
donné que c'était le rapporteur enfin le
président qui allait vous nommer à
lafsap
même tellement tellement le dialogue
était bon bref non je plaisante ce que
que je veux dire par là c'est que bon il
faut quand même dire qu'il y a eu il y a
quand même eu un raté hein ne pas nous
faire croire com ça s'est passé comme ça
et cetera et ce al la banque de données
certes elle existe maintenant tant mieux
bon B on espère qu'elle va servir pour
pour tout le reste
mais moi moi je suis je suis quand même
encore dubitatif je sors pas d'ici ah
ben ça y est ils ont compris non ça va
ça va s'arranger et puis ça va aller
mieux dans le meilleur des
Monsieur Le Men oui monsieur leou
d'accord un conseil vous nous avez dit
que les industriels étaient très
professionnels en fin de compte que même
vous les admiriez soit et alors que vous
souhaitiez d'ailleurs que tous les les
collaborateurs des autorités publiques
qui sont dans le monde du médicament
face donc à ces professionnels le soit
autant alors ma question qui se pose
c'est pourquoi euh les uns sont très
professionnels et les autres très
influençable à ces professionnels sans
être aussi professionnel pour s'opposer
aux 10 professionnels dont on voit bien
que le monde de l'industrie et des
laboratoires ce qui les rend très
professionnels c'est un retour financier
en ce qui les concerne par la vente de
leur produits alors que les autres
seraient plutôt non professionnels parce
que il y a un certain
laxisme par des chaînages au niveau de
l'expertise ou des accointance
passez-moi l'expression avec ces
industriels qui affaibliraient leur
vigilance et un laxisme des autorités
public qui emploie cette expertise et
que l'ensemble ferait que il serait
moins professionnel je dirais au sens
fort du
terme qui est de résister à d'autres
professionnels dans l'intérêt bien
évidemment des des malades qui l'intérêt
et qui des patients qui nous lit t
madame Jan
r merci monsieur le Président alors moi
c'est mes questions vont vous paraître
peut-être un un peu je vais pas dire
légère parce que c'est pas ça ne va pas
mais euh je n'appartiens ni au monde
médical ni paramédical ni pharmaceutique
j'ai tout à apprendre depuis que depuis
2h- 100 je suis là et je note et
j'essaie de d'apprendre et de comprendre
et je souhaiterais savoir Monsieur parce
que je n'ai pas noté monsieur le
professeur euh quand vous avez attiré
l'attention de LAPF sur le la véritable
utilité du médicament du médiateor vous
avez dit la date je l'ai pas noté et au
moment où où finalement vous avez posé
les vrais problèmes euh tout à l'heure
monsieur le Président vous avez dit
qu'il fallait très peu de temps pour
lancer un médicament et puis qu'il
faisait et qu'il fallait un temps très
long pour l'arrêter alors que moi je
croyais de que justement quand un
médicamament avait été découvert il
fallait au moins 7 ou 8 ans peut-être 10
ans avant qu'on le prenne en
considération et qu'on puisse le lancer
sur le marché alors j'aimerais savoir ce
qui est
vrai là et puis je voulais dire aussi
que quand un patient parce que moi je ne
suis qu'un patient euh quand quand un un
médecin vous prescrit des médicaments
moi je lis toujours toutes les notices
et bon parce que je me dis déjà j'ai son
diagnostic après je verrai au besoin je
préfère me soigner avec des méthodes de
grand-mère parce que quelquefois je lis
bon si vous avez des antécédents
d'asthme ne le prenez pas alors ça je
peux comprendre mais si vous avez déjà
si vous prenez des médicaments avec du
ou
avec auquel je ne comprends rien en du
tout voilà il peut y avoir des
interférences et ça peut-être grave et
dans ce cas prévenez vite prévenez vite
votre médecin donc je veux dire que
finalement les notices ne sont pas
toujours préhensibles pour pour les
béoien voilà
oui juste
juste qui attend quand même ah oui c'est
non
juste une petite question monsieur Alban
euh nous sommes en train dans dans le
cadre de cette commission de
regarder comment ça a pu se passer vous
avez donné une
explication il y a différents organismes
ceux qui donnent l'autorisation de mise
sur le marché ceux qui font la
surveillance ceux qui remboursent ceux
qui disent que ça va bien ceux qui
disent que ça va mal et à l'intérieur de
tout ça on dit que les laboratoires ont
une influence considérable et de ce que
j'ai entendu de votre not discussion
avec monsieur le Président et là je
rejoins monsieur caso euh il semblerait
que vous soyez assez d'accord pour dire
que la MM la pharmacovigigence le
remboursement du médicament puisse être
faite par le par le même organisateur
par le même organisme et à ce moment-là
est-ce que vous pensez pas que le
laboratoire va avoir une influence
encore plus
grande bon vous avez la parole monsieur
le
professeur donc je réponds à la question
de vous répondez oui non non mais je
suis je suis bien d'accord quand il y a
pas de question effectivement vous
pouvez pas répondre mais non non c'était
donc pour répondre à Madame c'était en
1998 que l'on avait fait notre notre
notre courrier et vous avez tout à tout
à fait raison de dire qu'il faut 7 ans
même 10 ans je crois pour avant de
pouvoir mettre un médicament sur le
marché de demander son autorisation de
mise sur le marché et c'est donc une
longue une longue histoire pour le
laboratoire un investissement
extrêmement important pendant ces 10
années d'où la la très grande difficulté
pour ceux qui ont en décidé d'accepter
ou de refuser une autorisation de mise
sur le marché parce qu'effectivement
pour le laboratoire c'est des enjeux
énormes et on conçoit la la difficulté
et je pense que c'est à ce moment-là
mais c'est difficile où il faut vraiment
se poser la question s'il y a un doute
il est pour le laboratoire ou il est
pour les patients et c'est très
difficile je vous
l'accorde pour les notices il y a
certainement effectivement des progrès
de communiation à faire au-delà de de de
notices un peu techniqu et qui peuvent
être aussi un peu angoissantes parfois
on a du mal à faire le la la la part de
de certains risques par rapport à
d'autres le pour pour pour la question
de que que vous posez monsieur
c'est je je ne dis pas qu'il faut fondre
les structures parce que je crois
que les sociétés fonctionnent bien quand
chacun a ses responsabilités et que tout
ça est en coordination non non je serais
plutôt au niveau que qu'il y ait des
experts qui à un moment donné dans un
lieu je parle de l'expertise là puissent
avoir en main l'ensemble des éléments
parce que je vois bien que par exemple
pour prendre l'exemple du médiateor à un
moment donné les experts qui
s'occupaient de la MM n'avaient pas les
mêmes idées que ceux qui s'occupaient de
la pharmacovigilance ils ont même été en
1900 à un moment donné je crois que
c'est je sais plus quelle année
exactement mais ces deux commissions
étaient en désaccord et en opposition
donc ce qui est exceptionnel ce qu'il
faut donc qu'il y ait des structures qui
ont une responsabilité sur la fixation
du du du du prix que d'autres soient
plus au niveau de la hiérarchisation et
de de service médical rendu non non
c'est qu'à un moment donné dans la vie
du médicament il y ait quand même un
groupe d'experts qui tiennent l'ensemble
de la germe qui tiennent l'ensemble de
la botte de ce que l'on connaît sur un
médicament parce que un médicament c'est
évolutif son bénéfice risque son son
seuil de bénéfice risque peut évoluer ça
sa place dans la thérapeutique peut
évoluer et c'est ça que je que que que
que que que que j'appelle c'est que des
les experts ne soient pas indépendants
entre eux au moins qu'ils communiquent
si on pouvait qu'ils soi coordonnés mais
qu'il y ait un endroit une intégration
de l'expertise sur un médicament et à
forciori s'il pose des vraies questions
ça me semblerait quand même une bonne
une une bonne option voilà donc je suis
pas sur l'intégration des structures
pourquoi pas il y a des choses qui
peuvent se faire d'autres non je pense
que il y aura des réflexions dans les
mois qui viennent sur le le le possible
de tout ça il y aura beaucoup d'avis je
crois qu'il faut qu'on s'écoute les les
autres mais c'était essentiellement sur
le champ de de l'expertise du que l'on
peut faire à un moment donné sur
l'intérêt d'un médicament en prenant en
compte simultanément ce que l'on sait de
ses données lorsqu'il a été mis sur le
marché de ce que l'on sait de ses
données de pharmacovigilance de ce que
l'on sait dans sa stratégie de
médicament de comment il est utilisé
dans la vraie vie en réel sur le terrain
comment on a tous ces éléments
maintenant et d'ailleurs c'est très
intéressant de voir que finalement le
rapport de Ligas a fait ce travail- làà
c'est-à-dire tout d'un coup il il a il
voit s'allumer tout ce qui a été fait
sur un médicament mais c'est des mêmes
personnes qui le regardent et tout d'un
coup qui font un constat qui aurait
peut-être pu faire s'il y avait eu un
audit sur le sur ce médicament par une
comité d'experts on aurait peut-être eu
cette affaire avant donc c'est ça que
j'appelle bien merci monsieur le
professeur de votre
contribution à ce débat qui aura pour
conclusion donc ce rapport qui
comportera des propositions
etesérant ser oui et qui nous esppérons
cette fois-ci oui sera lu hein
contrairement au précédent bon oui bon
merci beaucoup voilà pour ces deux
auditions de la mission d'information du
Sénat sur le Médiator si vous souhaitez
les revoir notre site internet
publsenat.fr prochain rendez-vous avec
l'actualité parlementaire c'est à 16h30
cet après-midi vous pourrez suivre
l'examen en seconde lecture du projet de
loi relatif au défenseurs des droits
très bonne journée à tous